[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
a storm is brewing you're never going to
beat hikarados on game not in these
positions within the Tempest the best
have come to test their skills and brave
the storm that means down to five
seconds gonna move
in dairy stuff right there for some this
is familiar ground I've never seen
Madness play a move like that Bishop
Ford Bishop oh oh for others this is a
Fresh Field to prove their prowess
dagger the moves will be fast oh my God
no 97
tricked at the end the stakes will be
high
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
passenger speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
that's Grand Master net Daniel
lareditzki I butchered your name to
start with I'm Grandmaster Robert Hess
and this is the 2022 speed Chess
Championship Donya we could not ask for
a better event to finish off the 2022
year
Robert hello everybody hello we
absolutely could not and what a way to
follow up the chess.com Global
championship this is really the only
worthy event uh to act as a follow-up to
the cgc I can't wait to jump in it's the
only event that would make me miss the
World Cup going on right now but you are
not gonna regret tuning in to this show
because there's a lot of prize money at
stake There are 16 great players in this
field and so in the opening round in the
round of 16 the players already are
playing for the big bucks Dania they
most certainly are you can see there the
main event price pool a cool 100 G's
2000 for the winner with an additional
2000 based on win percentage but the
players don't even really need any more
motivation hey they would play even on
the prize fund of zero but the price
fund is far from zero it certainly is
quite a bountiful event and with 16
worthy competitors in the field let's
just go ahead and take a look at the
bracket because that's all the people
want to see and we'll start in the top
right because Magnus Carlson makes his
trifling return to speed Chess
Championship Magnus Carlson could they
have invited anybody actually famous
anybody worthy of the SCC Magnus Carlson
on the top right ikar Nakamura on the
top left janapamnushi the world
championship Challenger on the bottom
right I mean wherever your eyes start to
it's like an all-your Buffet out there
oh my gosh we didn't even mention dingly
Wren the other World Chess Championship
Challenger he takes on Alexander
grashook a qualifier to this event
that's how you know it is super strong
grishuk had to qualify for this field
and yet in the first round dingley Wren
says I don't want to face that guy you
there's no one you want to face there's
no easy opponents in this field
including in that matchup between Magnus
and gukash but today Dania all eyes are
going to be on Fabiano caruana and Arjun
aragaisi that's exactly right I could
not think of a better way to kick off
the SCC as we look at their card there
Fabi Arjun look at their chess.com Blitz
ratings Arjun is over 3 100 and he's not
over 3 100 by accident
no he is not and Fabiano nearly 3100
himself winning a recent title Tuesday
these two have only played two times
that is not a lot of experience against
each other Fabiano himself has said that
when there's a more veteran player
against a teenager when they played a
lot that should favor the veteran but
here they have not and speaking of
quotes by Fabiano caruana he actually
talked about Arjun aragaisy on the
c-squared podcast and Donya he had some
big praise for his upcoming opponent big
praise indeed calling his chest
incredible on the podcast saying that
he's shown his constant level and
incremental Improvement and man Arjun
just blasted through the gates of 2700
he has stabilized he's denied anybody
who said that yeah you know he had a
couple of good tournaments no Arjun is a
full-fledged member of the super GM club
and Fabi doesn't just throw that kind of
Praise on to just anyone no he certainly
does not and Arjun has earned that
praise he helped Team India in the
Olympiad he had a fantastic performance
there he beat lenier Dominguez in that
one if I'm not mistaken so a great
performance indeed from Arjun aragaisy
in all of his tournaments and today he
has one opponent so we know how strong
Fabiano caruanas his preparation has
been universally praised he has World
Championship experience but that SCC
record two and five for Fabi he did beat
MBL Maxi Russia lagrav in the first
round last year but this is arjun's
first foray in the main SEC after win
winning the junior speeches Championship
over nihal sarin it is indeed the Slate
is clean as we look at our smarter chess
stats there we love to make fun of
smarter chess but this one time I'm
going to say that the predictions seem
pretty reasonable Fabi he's got the more
more experience he's got the pedigree
but Arjun he's got to be excited to be
in the main SEC bracket 67-33 the win
probability according to smarter chess
Robert as we'll talk about that's pretty
consistent with how the community saw it
I think that makes sense yeah I think
you know the slight lead in the longer
time goes does make sense as of right
now 500 car one is the stronger player
in classical chess longer in the time
Patrol with that increment usually
favors the stronger player but our
community did get involved as you
mentioned there were just about 15 000
brackets and probably the number still
Rising because you and I we literally
just filled out our bracket you have
four more minutes to do the same and
with the 710 matchup 71 percent of you
selected Fabiano caruana the other 29
for Argent era geissi that feels about
right
it feels about right and I think even
the most stalwart uh Fabiano caruana
fans will have to admit that this match
can go either way I mean you can see uh
the narrative going either way you could
see a lopsided match happening but I
most certainly hope that we will indeed
see a close match that comes down to the
bullet uh as a lot of these SEC matches
are want to do and you mentioned bullet
chest people would be like huh speed
Chess Championship what was that about
if this is your first time here welcome
if you're returning for the fun hey good
to have you back but this format is 16
players you win or you are out and with
the three time controls there's the five
minute plus one second increment three
minute plus one second agreement finally
one minute plus one second increment and
if it is all tied at the end of the
match we get four games of that bullet
time Patrol and then finally certainly
last but not least is Armageddon with
bidding that is always good fun I don't
think the players really want to get to
that point because it's super stressful
but these matches historically have been
that close they have been of course
what's stressful for the players is
delightful for the commentators and the
fans uh so it's a win-win no matter how
the match goes but I just love the SEC
format it's elegant and what I like
about it is that there isn't no time
control dominates the others you can
have a chance to come back in the bullet
you can perform well in one time control
and then flub the others so you get a
chance to display your Mastery across
the board
for sure I mean this is just a tale of
three type controls because some may say
well five minute chess what's the
difference between that and three minute
there is a big difference and when you
play 75 minutes of a five minute time
control and then you play in full hour
of three minute you may be a little bit
too slow in the quicker time patrols
because you get this muscle memory so
Dania I mean it's not easy to know when
to use your time and how to pace
yourself but these players in particular
Fabiano caruan in this match they have a
wealth of online Blitz experience
and that experience the importance of
that experience cannot be overstated you
have to be able to adjust mid-match uh
often we see players sticking to the
same openings all throughout the match
that's one thing that I'm curious about
right off the bat what are going to be
the players opening choices and who's
going to be the one shifting and
adjusting if things don't go quite
according to plan that's where that
experience especially the SEC experience
comes in and that's largely why I think
uh you know smarter chess and the
community is giving Fabian Edge yes and
I mentioned earlier the five minute car
wanna won a recent title Tuesday that is
no small feat concerning all the top
players who participate Hikaru Nakamura
seems to win them all when he's not
winning to meet you on Drake and we
didn't even mention his name he's facing
off against Levon aronian in the first
round matchup here in the SEC so just
all the best players with a few
exceptions some notable absences include
alireza farrugia but besides him you
just couldn't ask for more from a field
and the action's about to get underway
Donya I am super stoked no this is
amazing it's that feeling before you've
started unwrapping your birthday gifts
everything the Slate is clean we have so
many matches ahead of us this is a
glorious sensation as we see the players
there getting ready on camera I think
everyone's familiar with that room and
those wooden doors behind our generic I
see they're dreaded by his opponents
they are and I think there are a few
more trophies on the mantle because he
keeps winning events he has proven
himself he won the Tata steel
Challengers and next up will be the
Master's term will Fabiano caruana will
face off against Arjun In classical
chess for the first time ever
I think I'm actually matching with
Fabiano caruana you might be wearing the
same hoodie
is he just getting that botez live gear
is that boat says live gear and big
shout out to both says live sending me
all of this merch and the quality of the
soda cannot be overstated it's so
comfortable I think it's going to enter
my regular rotation that's saying a lot
because I have a lot of hoodies well it
looks like 500 carwana is talking to the
chess.com staff perhaps just getting
things figured out at the last second
there are generic guys he's looking cool
as ever that guy does not flinch no he
may be 19 years old but the way he is on
camera it seems like he's been through
everything and then so
oh yeah no he and he doesn't get too
high with the highs doesn't get too low
with the lows it's honestly unbelievable
that at his age he has acquired the kind
of composure the kind of mental
fortitude uh that he's displayed uh in
really every single match and it's not
for lack of passion he's incredibly
passionate he's driven he's just got
that composure which serves him so well
especially in those moments when the
match gets down to the wire
and in A Moment Like This some people
wait a lifetime for that first move
because so we are all excited here for
the speed Chess Championship to get
underway and well Arjun era Garcia you
don't know if he's already playing the
game you don't know if he just won or
lost he really is that calm cool and
collected and that should help him out
because we've seen him win the Junior
speech has Championship you may say
junior okay well that's not that big a
deal oftentimes the best players online
are the Juniors and he beat nihal sarin
last year's speeches Champion
semi-finals this year's cgc finalist so
that is clearly a Monumental task and he
did take down his friend and compatriot
yeah I mean taking down nihal siren an
absolutely Monumental task these days of
course nihil's most recent performance
wasn't too shabby Robert a second place
finish at the chess.com Global
Championship losing only to an
Unstoppable Wesley so so anybody who's
defeated nihalf starring in any format
in any tournament deserves the highest
praise Arjun just one of those guys that
nobody wants to face ever in any time
control
no no no no and the player is just
getting set and here we go go I see that
500 car one gets the white pieces in
game one and his rating it argents was
over 3 100 as of a couple days ago uh
fabianos was nearly 3100 himself but a
tough title twos they will do that to
you yeah a couple FM's in the first
couple rounds you know we know what
happens ah 30 50. I don't think we can
watch now and we were promised you know
two strong Grand Masters now we get some
scrubs ridiculous and we'd have an
exchange on D5 early there was a
triangle Pawn structure from black now
we see the light score Bishop opened up
and out to F5 but as soon as that Bishop
leaves Dania I'm always thinking can I
bring my queen to B3 go after the B7
Pawn or just play Simple development as
we're seeing from Fabi yeah we often see
in these positions the Queen's coming
out to B3 and then B6 and then kind of
entering a standoff that oftentimes can
last you know a dozen moves
right but look at probably playing H3 so
very calm choices from him and if you
cut the board in half white has that
extra Pawn from the middle E3 towards
the king side so it's likely that he
will just try to use that Advantage
whereas Black's Pawn majority on the
queen side it Pawn on C6 not going
anywhere anytime soon unless you want to
isolate a queen Pawn
yeah and a big question for white here
is where to develop this light squared
bishop or whether to develop it G4 from
Fabian that is actually why he played H3
wasn't only to create some love for his
dark squid Bishop it was also to go
after Black's light squared bishop and
Garner the bishop pair wow and we know
that top level players love themselves a
good Bishop with G4 included that does
have a bit of risk but then you say I
know my coaches tell me not to play G4
but what is the problem here White's
King is safe in the center and now we're
gonna see a series of Trades and after
those trades I don't think the white
king will be in any serious Danger
no although if you play in cautiously I
actually don't think Fabi should take on
e4 because after de4 there's going to be
all sorts of threats along the A5 E1
diagonal so probably Fabi should keep
his Knight on C3 and he does and we
might see a trade on C3 and then the
pawn structure is going to change and
that actually might be a bit of bad news
along with good news for Fabi because
with Knight takes C3 b63 I think black
and quickly played Knight B6 and take
over that C4 square but then you're sort
of adjusting your pieces to the wrong
flank because white does have that extra
Pawn in the center so I'm not quite sure
that even if a black knight ends up on
C4 if that really does much of anything
yeah it's really not the end of the
world Arjun fixes the king side
structure driving his Pawn up to G5
chasing the bishop back to H2 presumably
and my guess is that Fabi is going to
Castle kingside even though he's played
the move G4 the pawn on H3 is very
safely defended By the uncontested Light
skirt Bishop you called it Robert a
knight has indeed appeared on B6 I I
like fabby's position though I feel like
his structure is very Dynamic Arjun
trying to get rid of his Bishop there
but nonetheless I think Fabi secured
himself a nice opening Advantage here
yeah and I'm wondering about moves like
F4 at some point I know that there's a
lot of risk to that move because E3
becomes a Target but instead Fabi trades
on D6 and what is the plan here maybe
it's to expand on the queen side at some
point he starts The Rook B1 I was gonna
say A4 A5 and then try to uh open up the
queen side and especially that B7 pawns
a semi-open file and I think that is
fabby's idea but I wouldn't rule out
queenside Castle here for Arjun from
black side ooh Castle's kingside waited
for me to say that no he's playing fully
positionally you know that's like in
hand and brain when someone says King
you know they want a castle you're not
sure if we go the wrong way he went
castle kingside and I I liked your plan
more castling Queen side it was a
dynamic choice and I think Arjun in game
one with the black pieces he just wants
to be solid but I do think he's solidly
worse if Fabiano is able to play A4 and
push that part of the board create
issues down the B file and I don't see a
compelling reason why he should not play
A4 after A4 well I cannot play A5 that
drops the Knight now probably black
should respond by defending the B7 Pawn
to pave the way for Knight C4 but then
why could you consider something like
Rook B4 maybe double on the on the beef
off Fabby takes a different approach to
Rook te1 is he trying to prepare E4
Robert and is there a case to be made
for F5 I liked F5 because now white
should play E4 if you don't play it now
you may never get that opportunity with
the move F5 on tap for black so Arjun
tries to make E4 less likely but still
is a viable choice for fobby and I think
he must go for it otherwise he's worse
and that's why he plays it he's done it
and we might see a trade on e4 and we we
might see a total liquidation down the
e-file if both pairs of Rooks get traded
I think a draw uh becomes quite likely
it seems that both players are kind of
feeling each other out here in the
opening game neither side really wanting
to take too many risks at this point the
position I think is probably about
balanced yeah and there are some
Dynamics here that you have to account
for that White's Pawn structure with the
Iceland a pawn that could become a
target for example Queen A3 in the near
future hits A2 and C3 the good news is
that Queen can always slide back to C2
for white but the point is that there
are some things that white you need to
be concerned about and then black has
this Pawn on G5 that sticks out like a
sore thumb the Knight on B6 can't move
because it's sort of pinned down to the
B7 Pawn so both sides have their pluses
and minuses yeah they most certainly do
and there's also kind of a low-key
battle going on for control over the
e-file currently white holds the e-file
but it's not the end of the world there
are no real infiltration squares but
with this last move Queen D6 to d8 if
given the opportunity arjun's going to
slide his Rook over to E8 but if Fabby
moves his Rook from B1 to E1 Robert the
downside of that is that the Knight is
free to roam about the cabin and the
last thing you want is to let the Knight
stick itself on F4 that's correct so
that's why if it's Queen D3 he gets off
the e-file rookie it's still possible
but maybe five would play C4 we keep
talking about kicking the Knight out of
B6 C4 followed by C5 is another option
and I actually like the look of C4 right
now and I think Arjun is going to
respond by sliding his Rook over to d8
and hitting that newly weakened Pawn on
D4 nonetheless I agree I think C4 is the
most ambitious approach and it's on the
board okay and Rook d8 so white can play
C5 there is no Queen takes C5 tactics in
that position but you give up the D5
score so keeping the pawns those hanging
pawns where they are is often important
you take away squares from your
opponent's pieces yeah this has largely
been all about trying to restrict the
mobility of this Knight on B6 which Fabi
has done a great job of but obviously it
comes with the cost of these weak pawns
on D4 and C4 they're literally
simultaneously as strength uh and
White's biggest strength perhaps and
White's biggest weakness yeah and that
Bishop on G2 it's kind of just waiting
in the wings there at some point you can
consider the move D5 especially if the
Knight moves from B6 but the problem is
to move that knife from B6 you might
have to play C5 and then you lose
control of the D5 Square so they're
jostling for control over the center and
Rook D7 giving another other Defenders
the B7 here Queen to F6 go right after
the D4 Pawn what is fabi's idea yeah how
is Fabi planning to defend that pawn
instead Arjun moves the queen back to d8
allowing The Rook to slide into E4 but
Robert if the queen were on F6 I think
black would have had the additional
resource C5 and white would have landed
in a lot of trouble Queen d8 might have
been a little bit too conservative on
arjun's part yeah maybe Queen F6 he
didn't like little Rook to E5 defending
the pawn by blocking the Queen's
diagonal so there were some tricks there
but right now he reroutes the knight at
long last my Coach mirror always taught
me Knights on B3 G3 B6 and G6 were the
worst place pieces because they often
stay there for like the rest of the game
so here the Knight has rerouted C8
Knight D6 is an option but after Rook E5
I don't think you could take on C4
because of Rook E8 check so the Knight
is Frozen on D6 I'll quickly show this
on the analysis board Knight takes E4
rookie a check and you might say hey
whites Queen is hanging as well but
after Rook takes the eight Knight takes
C3 the Rook on D7 is also hanging and
white wins the game and because of this
line Arjun starts by preemptively
prophylactically moving his King up to
G7 obviously Knight takes E4 is now a
huge threat Fabby has many ways to
defend that pawn though Robert he can
move his Queen back he can move his
Bishop back Queen E2 is on the board and
look at the clocks we haven't talked
about time management both players are
doing a good job with respect to that
but now a minute 10 seconds for Arjun A
Min and a half for Fabi we're getting to
that sort of bullet phase and you may
say look at the Eva bars right in the
middle it's equal they're gonna make a
draw this is anything but clear this
position with his Knight going back and
forth the D4 Pawn loose but White's
activity with the queen of Rook on the
e-file and that Bishop on G2 at some
point and there it is D5 has been played
that Bishop join the party it absolutely
may join the party on T5 and Arjun
trying to prevent that from happening
pushing C5 and it's so important that
the Knight can jump into D6 that is the
best blockading Square on the board from
a practical perspective I really like
the speed with which you made that
decision and okay Fabio's trying to
prevent him from getting the ideal setup
Knight D6 though is still possible Right
96 Bishop F1 is almost premovable you
need a defense C4 now a for ANSI for
under attack so you take A4 but then
does white capture on G5 and then move
the Rook back to E5 and try to play G5
himself and go for attack it might be a
little bit slow especially with black
getting it outside and this is why it's
opportunity to create something on the
king side while the Knight is out of
commission on A4 but black is still so
solid and that's exactly what Fabi tries
to do that's a brilliant move oh my
goodness and you take on H4 there's G5
the queen would have to go back but look
at Argentina's attention tries to trade
Queens that's a great decision from him
fantastic decision with 40 seconds left
now the Queens are gonna get traded and
it's hard to evaluate that resulting
position White's got that Monster Pawn
on D5 but no Arjun takes the pawn on G4
we might still see a queen trade if
Fabby covers with his Queen but I think
Fabio's gonna try to keep keep the
Queens on the board and get his Rook to
E8 Paving the way for potentially a
mating net although if King H2 if you
try to avoid things Rook d8 h8 is
awesome so he plays Bishop G2 he gives
up the C4 Pawn the pawn count is not
important you just mentioned the King on
G7 is quite vulnerable so Queen H3 is in
the air but not right now because the E5
Rook is hanging I thought Arjun could
have maybe tried to force a Perpetual to
check on D1 instead he's trying to force
a queen trade Fabi could decline that
trade with Queen G3 Robert but look at
the clock he's now down to about 15
seconds and he plays rookie he gives the
queen trade and is this idea just he
takes the pawn he wants to throw that
pawn off the board E4 E5 E6 happens
faster than you think and he wants to
combine that with the move Bishop H3
dislodging the black Rogue from D7 but
is that going to be fast enough Arjun is
going a hunting for some of White's
pawns and here goes the a pawn and there
goes the a pawn it's too slow for Fabi
because he needs to play Bishop H3 there
and now A4 A3 A2 is fast in fact eight
four right four what A4 sack The Rook
can go A3 yeah the rule can't get back
this is insane the A8 square is
protected by that Knight and he plays it
what a fine from origin era geisie he
just throws the pawn up the board and is
Unstoppable A2 you can even take the
bishop on D7 if you want now it's a
paper tiger just King f8 evade the
checks there's actually a Perpetual
threat oh look at Fabby exhausting every
last resource okay the king is King f8
only move yeah I think you have to go
there four seconds for Arjun oh we
missed it oh he allowed to draw oh my
goodness or does he want Queen G7 seven
he's gonna play on but that might lose
so he's gonna go for the draw a good one
what did we just see in game one we're
gonna have to rewind and show the win
that he just missed that was surprising
I first of all Fabi allowed that pawn to
run up the board but then for Arjun in
the winning position to let it slip that
is not what we're accustomed to seeing
and with his last seconds he just forgot
Robert that you can drop the king back
to f8 you don't care about this Pawn per
se what you care about is that that pawn
leads to Perpetual now the king just
safely walks over to E8 where I can try
D6 but something like Queen E5 solves
all of the problems black and just give
the night up for the pawn and the game
is over wow right a huge Mission look
what we're getting in game two you say
wow about game one Fabiano up his rook
in the corner now it's an opening that
is actually quite well known uh we're
not quite into novel territory yet I
don't believe but this Rook was given up
on A8 and look at the compensation in
the form of White's lack of development
this Knight on G5 is awkward if it gets
kicked it might have to go to H3 or
something point so I mean you better be
well prepared and if there's any player
with well prepared is using the sentence
it's Fabiano
it definitely is I would be terrified to
have this position with the white pieces
Knight C6 to D4 Robert comes to mind if
you take the Knight you get checkmated
it's on the board you also can't Castle
kingside because of the fork on E2 how
does Arjun okay well there's the answer
Knight A3 and now the bishop is
protected by The Rook which is so
crucial because CD is now a huge threat
and if you take on A3 removing the guard
of C2 as you just point out C takes D4
is available but what about Knight E2
for black you don't see a move like this
very often but that Queen has to move
out the way and then the Knight can even
go to F4 so your knight is just kind of
journeying across and he does take what
three but what
what C takes D4 and white is just
winning
no I mean or am I overestimating this
maybe it's not the simplest position but
it looks like it's just bad for black
and the Eva I mean Skyrocket listen for
starters white could just Castle
kingside here I don't think that's the
best move it looks like Knight E4
basically ends the game on the spot but
even after Castle's King side E4 Queen
H4 clearly White's initiative is fizzled
out and Arjun has found the best move
and he's done it with over four minutes
left on his clock and you could tell by
fabi's face that he was yeah no exactly
he just made his face pulled his hair
and he's like what did I just do so he
knew the opening and then he must have
forgotten how to continue and in Blitz
chess when you don't have 30 minutes to
sit and think on the position this is
the danger of sacrificing material in
the opening and done it you made this
point earlier some players they play the
same opening over and over again others
they just switch up the positions I
think that Fabiano at the halftime break
in this time control he'll probably go
and study it but I would not repeat that
until I've had a solid look at the line
oh without question and this is a total
catastrophe and the game is just over
because after Knight takes E4 Queen
takes rewind Fabi might resign here and
now remember the white is up in exchange
in a pawn you're gonna drop another Pawn
on G7 at this point there's no
compensation and Arjun wins game two in
15 moves and they call you the profit
for a reason you call that resignation
origin aragaisy in a miniature victory
over Fabiano some help from his opponent
but now we're getting some more quiet
lines at least in this canal attack with
Bishop E5 check we'll see what Fabi has
prepared Knight D7 this has become the
topical way to counter these checks is
because instead of trading Bishops and
just having a quiet game she's like no
at some point I'll play A6 you'll have
to drop back or take me and we'll just
leave your Bishop on B5 for now
and a big choice in the early going for
white is whether he will position his
Pawn on D3 that's the kind of more
modest close Sicilian type setup of
course you could also play the move d4
and then the game largely transitions
into a dragon or Dragon dwarf type
structure there we see Fabby pushing his
Pawn up to D3 I like this Choice after a
game like the previous one you want to
stabilize you want to do something on
the quieter side and these are the kinds
of maneuvering games in which Fabi
excels wow A5 was like five yeah what a
move I just didn't see why that was
necessary but Arjun played it very
quickly which means he knows this
position and as we look the B6 Pawn is
going to fall so what's the dynamic left
that A5 is isolated there's a rook on A1
that's good news but the bishop on G7 is
the best minor piece on the board it's
just slicing across the position and
that means that B2 will also be a Target
because you can't push it up the board
otherwise you fall victim some tactics
yeah the queen Side Pawn structure is
kind of reminiscent of a Banco game but
obviously black has not sacrificed on so
you have a clear upside and downside the
pawn on A5 it's a weakness but it could
also turn into a strength later down the
road especially in conjunction with that
G7 Bishop you can think about like
Knight D7 and A4 A3 A4 is on the board
but Robert he's allowed white to root
out the dark squared Bishop with the
bishop H6 was that necessary great
choice by Fabiano I'm just I'm gonna say
just looking at the way this game is
gone the compact nature of the position
no tactics no misses available for him
he's in a position where if he plays
normal chess it's gonna be hard for
Arjun to defend the whole time but if
Arjun does defend well he'll make a draw
this is a locked position the A4 Pawn
the biggest weakness thus far so I think
that both sides are playing well in this
game I think it's a good overall
strategy from Fabi agreed but I loved
arjun's last move E7 E5 might seem
anti-positional but look how he follows
it up he now strikes with D5 exploiting
the fact that White's pieces are kind of
temporarily uncoordinated of course
black is gonna have to be really careful
to compensate his bad Pawn structure
with active piece play and he hasn't
even taken back on D5 so we'll be this
be the second time in the game where he
doesn't take back a pawn that he's just
offered but I think his problem is if he
takes on D5 Bishop F3 happened and then
a rook comes to E1 as you were just
highlighting before E5 not the biggest
Target because you can always play F6
but C5 and A4 are both isolated and can
be attacked with relative e so I'm
nervous about the long-term prospects of
arjun's position but I like his activity
for now
I like I liked Bishop F3 a lot instead
Fabi plays it even simpler he just takes
on D5 and he might still play the move
Bishop F3 if Arjun recaptures with the
Knight of Fury captures with the queen
then he will definitely play Bishop F3
and don't fall asleep on this H2 Knight
before you know it in the blink of an
eye the knife can jump into G4 and you
actually cannot stop the check on H6 so
Arjun has to keep an Eagle Eye on the
proceedings on the king side make sure
the Knight G4 doesn't lead to checkmate
yeah no this is actually a quite a scary
position for Arjun because Knight G4 you
can stop with H5 but that's really not a
movie you want to play both because your
king can be in danger in other ways but
he plays Queen C7 so he's protecting E5
that way he can meet Knight G4 with a
pawn push like F5 for example uh
Sometimes the best way to defend your
king is actually by striking towards the
center and expanding your position so
the E5 Pawn is under control and now he
needs to keep that part under control
because Knight G4 is a big threat it's a
huge threat Queen H6 Knight takes E5 so
Arjun could bring his own Rook to E8 but
one thing that could happen Robert if he
does that after rookie eight white could
very seriously consider something like
Bishop takes D5 and only now Knight G4
on the point is that after F5 Queen H6
check black basically loses the game
because the Knight is jumping into F6
with devastating effects so instead
Arjun making a more solid move he plays
F7 F6 trying to permanently defend the
C5 Pawn to take this headache off of his
mind
if I were playing bullet I would have
made a move like Rook E4 just trying to
bring the Rook to H4 but instead he
trades and plays Knight G4 we see his
clear intentions for one Queen H6 check
but also Knight back to E3 the Knight on
H2 wasn't doing anything the Knight on
E3 may even venture to C4 at some point
but we talked about this some of White's
pawns are also weak B2 is now under
attack G2 is threatened so Knight E3
does protect G2 while attacking D5 but
B2 remains a bit of an issue but Arjun
just seems so comfortable in the early
going it appears to me that he's managed
to disarm what I thought was a sort of
long-term positional Edge that Bishop on
D5 it can drop back to E6 and as long as
it keeps the Knight on E3 fully
restricted I think black is actually
doing all right here
for sure no this actually looks very
pleasant uh you know I like to say a
pawn three squares away from Knight
dominates the Knight a bishop does even
better because it takes away F5 G4 D5
and C4 from where that Knight can go and
look at Fabi he orients his Rooks on the
queen side in an important moment there
were e to be one that Rook on A1 is
necessary and queen B4 wow he's trying
to get another past a pawn and he's
playing this kind of boa constrictor
style he's stopping Fabby from even
thinking about developing Queen side
activity Bobby keeps the Queens on the
board Queen takes B4 was totally
Unthinkable that pawn would appear on A2
before you finished eating your
breakfast
I have not eaten breakfast today so yeah
neither it happens is before I haven't
even had coffee oh gosh I know how much
you need that but right now Rook F to d8
is there a threat maybe Pawn E4 it
probably brings The Rook up to A3
allowing E4 or C4 opponent D3 is pinned
so it's a big moment here for Arjun and
he's over two minutes to think about it
he didn't need much time no he did not
he pushes the pawn to C4 preserving the
sort of Integrity of his kingside Pawn
structure and not only does he eradicate
one of his weaknesses but just look at
the pressure that he is exerting on
fabi's D3 Pawn this could be trouble for
white yet again and this B2 Pawn is just
like this eternal weakness because in
some positions that Bishop on E6 May
land on A2 you may think what is Robert
talking about but the Rook on B1 is the
lone defender of that pawn so if some
trades happen and you're met with Bishop
of A2 you'll lose B2 and then the eight
four Pawn becomes a passer I'll show a
sample line because that's a great point
this is how quickly it can happen Bishop
A2 get off me Rook C1 Queen takes B2
there's a total paper tiger on C7 easily
blocked by the bishop and white can
resign is that a pawn the red carpet has
been unrolled so this is not a
far-fetched reality let's see what Fabi
has done he's played the move C3 chasing
the queen away but now the D3 Pawn is
even weaker how is he going to meet a
move like Queen C5 he might be trying to
give up D3 for A4 some kind of trade
like that but this is getting dicey and
I don't really like it maybe he also is
willing to play D4 just give up a pawn
because when you look at that pawn
deficit it's an A4 and C4 Pawn both of
them not incredibly strong and so he
might just give the pawn in that way but
otherwise he's taking on A4
he's definitely going to take on A4 here
and then Arjun is going to I think play
C takes D3 getting a massive pass Pawn
on D3 of course white technically also
will have not one but actually two past
pawns on the queen side and I think Fabi
is banking on the fact that that Knight
on E3 is actually a pretty solid
defensive piece guarding the D1 Square
oh never mind he's played D4 hey you
called it you're the prophet but I guess
I'm the Fabi Whisperer and D4 happens
here and it's a big decision but I think
what he's banking on is the fact that
those isolated pawns on the queen side
so even though he's down upon he
probably feels like he has very good
chances to hold because black will be
distracted defending those Pawns of the
time being yeah but I think for Arjun
the key is to combine defense and attack
which is exactly what he's doing Queen
to B4 securing the A4 pawn and Paving
the way for a very nasty Rook
infiltration to the second Rank and
queen C3 it's what Bobby's relying on
he's just saying let's trade those
Queens off the board I know you have
extra material but where are those pawns
going they're stuck in place so I think
it's a very good decision from Fabiano
he's down to a minute in three seconds
so that's what we need to watch out for
uh we were there in Toronto and the
players were discussing the strengths
and weaknesses and when Anish and Fabi
they were you know just kind of ripping
each other what Anish was saying is you
know Fabi when he has little time on the
clock he may struggle the most out of
all players in this field
that's exactly right and you can see
Arjun doing his best to keep the Queens
on the board now he can drop his Queen
back to D7 he might say oh but white has
Rook takes A4 in that position no he
doesn't I can show that line really
quickly Queen D7 Rook takes A4 and no
this doesn't blunder The Rook but it
allows the devastating Intermezzo Rook
D1 check putting the Rook on a defended
square and When the Smoke Clears black
is going to be up a bishop so that's not
possible instead
a rook has appeared on D3 so Arjun not
playing Queen D7 and Knight C4 and he
goes with his work he wants Rook C8 at
the end but there might be B3 here what
oh my gosh B3 oh B3 Rook a seven exactly
and the King on G7 isn't grave danger so
B3 is the only move and that's the only
move for Fabi because once you find it
actually puts black in trouble actually
Queen D2 I think might also defend and
he's played Queen D2 but that end game
looks real nasty there's a bishop that
can appear on B3 and if Arjun can keep
his a-pawn protected he's going to win
okay but the problem is Bishop B3 Knight
D4 and you chop on B3 white may go down
a pawn but there's resulting rook and
pawn end games with just one extra Pawn
for black should be within the realm of
a draw so Argent should play this out
five only is 21 seconds and he's trying
to find the most confusing line possible
yeah because the F2 Pawn is hanging B2
is hanging you could get a three on two
on the king side I don't think that's
the the best winning attempt I think he
should go for Bishop B3 and try to trick
Fabian the ensuing Rook end game Arjun
now down to 30 seconds himself and he's
gone the simple route just taking on F2
and on B2 he's trying to sort of keep
the game going prolong it and that means
there's more room for Fabiano to make a
mistake I guess I shouldn't say more
room that sounds like he has a luxury no
he needs to avoid making a mistake but
Rook A6 is just simple he's just given
up his winning chances Rook A7 you
cannot keep all the pawns protected at
once
nicely done nicely done by Fabi here
Queen D2 and the way to salvage is half
point and after Rook F6
is there something like King G7 G5 that
he's going for I don't think it works
Rook F5 only move actually without Rook
F5 it would be a loss arjun's still
trying to keep his foot on the gas pedal
but Fabi is now fully out of the woods
and that is tantamount to a draw for yes
so I think the players repeating moves
no draw offers thank you they know how
mad I get about the draw for but we have
a two to one lead for Arjun aragazu so
for everybody in chat who thought that
500 would win this time segment so far
it's looking like Arjun is trying to
spoil your prediction
yeah Arjun has demonstrated great form
that was a good defensive effort though
for Fabian that was an important game
because you lose that one with the white
pieces you go down two points you start
entering that unpleasant Zone where hey
one more lost you're settling down three
points instead Bobby keeps the deficit
at one and now essaying another very
solid opening the Petrov let's see how
he handles this interesting structure
with the white Pawn on E5
right and we see that in this setup
white plays Knight to D2 black avoids
the trades and plays Knight C5 these
types of positions are in Fabiano's
wheelhouse he is a Petrov Maestro and
Arjun already spending some time so
that's not necessarily a bad sign for
Arjun but I think it would give me
confidence in Fabi because of his
tremendous success in the past in the
Petrov I might be influenced by the eval
bar but I strongly dislike the way that
arjuna's handled the opening first of
all D takes E5 is obviously a relatively
rare sideline but it's been a frequent
guest at the top level recently but what
I don't like is that he's given up his
light squared Bishop he's now saddled
with weaknesses in the center this is
like an ideal like Karo Khan type of
setup with the white the black light
squirt Bishop on a perfect square and
night before could come to mind maybe
even F6 to open up the center am I
overestimating this no night before it
looks really tempting I guess why has
this move Rook E2 just to cover the fork
on the C2 square but Bobby sees
something he likes maybe I play C5 I
love it normally we say oh isolated
Queen Pawn that doesn't look great but
white is kind of discombobulated black
has the two Bishops in particular this
light Square Bishop on G6 is a menace
and if you think you're just playing A3
and all is over no white black can you
put that Knight on D3 if he wants yeah I
mean A3 Knight D3 and then maybe
securing the Knight with C4 Arjun has to
be very careful these next couple of
moves this could get out of control
really easily if Arjun doesn't handle
this with the utmost caution right dc5
Bishop C5 that just brings another piece
into the attack if you don't take maybe
black will play C4 and dig that D3
Square uh for his pieces I mean this
just feels like a rough moment for Arjun
the good news is the longest time
control he can use some time here to
figure out what to do and he plays A3
okay he plays A3 and the big question
now for Fabi is whether he should leap
into D3 or drop the Knight back to C6
which is not just a passive move Knight
C6 applies pressure on D4 and I would
say virtually forces white uh to to
settle matters in the center with d
takes C5 what do you think he's gonna do
I would go Knight D3 for sure but that
means Bobby's probably playing Knight C6
because 93 you're the Fabi whisper have
some Faith only on occasion and I feel
like Knight D3 is the move that everyone
wants to play it's aggressive but it
might not actually be best sometimes we
are lured into an idea that is just a
one move threat that he does play Knight
C6 and that actually is a sign of look
at this he doesn't even take back oh he
plays D4 he wants D3 he'll take back on
C5 next or if white plays B4 as he just
did he can also play A5 he can strike on
all sides he most certainly can that
Bishop on G6 is such a beast it's sort
of an extension of the Pawn on D3 and if
you're Arjun well first of all you have
to decide where you're putting the Rook
E1 D2 E3 all those moves are possible
obviously in an Ideal World Arjun would
try to surround and win the D3 Pawn but
Robert even if he wins the D3 Pawn that
doesn't signal an end to Black's piece
activity in fact that might just be the
beginning with the defile getting opened
yeah this bishop on G6 is Untouchable so
you could surround it but it'll take all
of your pieces just to attack it and
right now Black's next move is A5 you
don't want to push B5 if you're white
because then C5 will drop you've just
carved out the D4 Square for a night
trade if you're fobby Queen can just go
up to D5 I really like that square bring
a rook to d8 get behind your pass Pawn
so I feel like I'm looking at like six
different options for black and every
single move is difficult for white it's
a concept we talk about a lot down there
where one player just practically
speaking has an easier time yeah I think
in a three minute game this would
virtually be over as it stands arjun's
still with two and a half minutes to
handle this defensive task he moves his
Rook back to E1 there's your move Queen
D5 and the speed with which Fabi plays
just indicates how practically easy this
type of position is to handle with black
but the position is not going to win
itself uh Robert and I think what Arjun
is saying is hey I'm gonna get my pieces
out everything is solid for the time
being maybe it's time to strike at the
queen side with A5 and create new
weaknesses if you're fobby
right no I like that plan and there's a
moment for white to play E6 like if
you're not careful for Fabi and that
move gets flicked in the bishop on B2 is
going to make its presence felt so for
now Arjun is keeping everything together
there could be a queen B3 at some moment
uh B6 is also possible here because you
can't take on B6 you lose B4
um so I feel like maybe I overestimated
fabi's chances and Arjun is just playing
the perfect responses he is up upon
after all so even if it costs him a pawn
somewhere down the line here then it's
just even material he's doing the whole
ice water in his veins thing again he
took a little bit of time he sort of
readjusted himself and he's keeping the
position together I think after Bishop
to C3 I'm not exactly sure how fabi's
gonna follow this up instead Arjun goes
aggressive with H4 wow that is a big
decision from Arjun because he's trying
to trap the bishop on G6 but if black
plays H5 then that pawn on H4 actually
can become a long-term weakness that
pawn can be attacked there's already
Bishop on the E7 so I like the
aggression and he also creates lust for
his King but that can be picked off
later in the game that's a great point
it's hard to say who this favors in the
long run instead Fabi goes H6 allowing
Arjun to drive that pawn down to H5 not
sure I love that decision and now I
think Bishop C3 is going to follow
you've got to keep this Pawn on B4
protected at all costs
and I'm really tempted by the move E6 as
well oh yeah it's good right now it
doesn't really carry a threat he plays
your decision Bishop C3 so Fabian up a
little bit of time but I do believe that
Arjun has played masterfully here H4 H5
just driving the pawn forward now black
is the one with back rank problems
there's no escape on H7 because the
bishop is where the king eventually was
going to go yeah and let's not forget
the Fabi is down a pawn so with every
heavy piece that disappears off the
board the significance of White's
material advantage old and gross 94-96 a
potential idea suddenly that Bishop on
H7 not looking quite like the Beast that
it was a couple moves ago no but a rook
does belong behind a pass Pawn Knight E4
to D6 is an option but there could be
like a rook takes A1 and then White's
pieces get scattered because you would
like to take back on A1 with a rook but
the E4 Knight would be loose so you just
need to figure out how this works you
don't want to take an A8 then you give
an a file to Black so ah it's not an
easy choice and Argent down under a
minute and about 35 sec seconds yeah
that's the problem with these types of
positions you might look at the eval bar
and say hey White's better well maybe
technically white is better but the
nature of the position Remains the Same
and it's still very very hard to handle
so easy to make a mistake accidentally
give up the a file I'm tempted by the
move Rook a to B1 maybe you can try to
put the Rook on B2 but Arjun he slides
the other Rook over to C1 so he is
Robert adopting a defensive posture here
trying to make sure that everything is
defended seven times over and he didn't
want to allow Queen C2 at any moment
because of course you don't want to
trade on C2 Point give black this more
advanced pass Pawn so Rook C1 is frees
up the queen and I like that move so
what's fabi's idea here he can trade
Rooks but that just helps white it feels
maybe he can I just you know I said
maybe I didn't have a thought after it
listen Fabi made all of the typical
improving moves he played Queen D5 he
played Rook D but eventually your pool
of these types of moves is going to get
exhausted and it's just been exhausted
suddenly the time the time situation is
starting to equalize eyes and soon we
might be saying that Black's position is
actually the harder position to play
here
I think the Knight on C6 needs to be
improved so I'm actually looking at the
move Knight A7 to go to B5 it looks
ridiculous but I want that Knight on a
better square instead follow me trades
works and with Queen C4 so where is that
Queen going is it going to G4 at some
point I'm not really sure but white also
has a difficult move to make
it most certainly does and you mentioned
improving the night maybe white can try
to improve the G3 Knight and reroute it
over to E3 still I'm not exactly sure
what the final destination is I'm also
thinking about well I was thinking about
rookie one but again the last thing you
want to do is give up control of the a
file so I think Arjun he's going to keep
his Rook on A1 no he's not he's going to
play Rook B1 not sure I like that move
though and Knight A7 here comes that
revising the night is called the B5 look
at the lights with an E6 version at last
he's played the movies opened the bishop
and I think he's done it at a pretty
good time all things considered right
because if Queen E6 rookie won the
bishop on E7 is a bit loose so the queen
would have to go to D7 the 95 with Tempo
so the Knight on C6 was guarding the
bishop on E7 and that's why in chess
every little detail is relevant so is
five you can take with the pawn on E6 he
does in fact do that but that's quite
risky for his King safety yeah and now
that pawn on H5 is really sitting pretty
clamping down on the king side just the
presence of mind Robert to play E6
instantly but is that going to solve all
of White's problems the Knight has
jumped into B5 Queen C2 is tempting but
there's no way in heck that White's
gonna trade Queens there no and Rook A8
is also tempting let's bring that Rook
to the open file Knight C7 just to
protect E6 and maybe go Knight D5 and
attack B4 that makes sense as well I
feel like black just has the easier next
set of moves still origin he needs to
prove that that pawn sacrifice just now
was worth it and he's opened up his
Bishop but look at how carefully Fabby
handles that position Bishop fa
prophylaxis protect G7 that's a good
move given that they're entering the
time scramble phase
and queen D5 just bring the queen back I
just don't see ideas for white right now
92 just block hating and Knight season 2
was coming but now you can maybe take on
E6 now that the D3 Pawn is blockaded you
could actually go into the end game no
he keeps the Queens on the board and he
prepares rookie five
okay big decision I think Queen trade
seem like impossible for white just
because of the past Pawn on D3 the Eva
bar said it was a better move but a
queen goes back to some Bishop C3 and
now what's the idea for black I feel
like white is getting some momentum and
now Bishop E7 bringing the bishop back
Queen C4 excellent move and the E6 Pawn
is now under serious fire and we have a
bullet scramble oh Bobby doesn't see a
move here
14 seconds King F7 and now Knight F5 is
very tempting he goes 94 instead oh and
there goes nice Factory that night has
gone ever go Knight A7 to C6 that would
be really fun it's gone Around the World
in 80 Days but again fabi's position is
now definitely the harder one to play
Arjun could even bring his other Knight
back out from D2 and he does and the
King just goes back to jail what a big
decision by Fabi and D2 he gives him his
pass Pawn because he wants to trade on
D6 I mean maybe Arjun shouldn't have
rushed with Knight takes D2 because the
promotion score was protected by the
queen still I kind of like White's
position here that Bishop on B2 could
wreak havoc on Black's King if you blink
and watch out for Knight F4 these cute
66. they both take it but Knight F4 now
who has better attack instead he goes
Bishop F5 he's trying to protect that E6
spawn at all costs
and it's just time scramble right now B5
to keep that pawn safe nothing
threatened Queen G5 I might play at some
point
oh there's so many forks and pins here
the G4 Square needs to be protected and
hey coach G4 Arch and put something on
there he missed it Knight takes G4 Queen
H5 Queen H5 but Argent blunder is the B
Pawn
oh now fabby's taking over oh Queen 65
was there Queen we'll have to show that
after the game Queen F1 oh she trades
Queens instead out of fear
out of fear but that gives Arjun great
defensive chances I think this is a draw
now Knight D4 picks upon oh hey bishop
D1 oh it's so many chances now he's
gonna give up G7
wow that's a big king F6 F7 Knight C5
okay there was a save there so we're
seeing a bunch of Trades opposite code
Bishops but three seconds per side I
think we are going to have a draw
unbelievable and that that was a lot of
missed opportunities there at the end
for Fabi but can you really blame him
with two seconds on the clock
um I can't blame him but if you want to
win the speed Chess Championship even a
single match you need to win games let's
show that moment with Queen takes E5
there there was that was a big moment
and that was something he should have
seen I think that's the one thing which
you can see you know in the blink of an
eye and you have to see in the blink of
an eye okay let me pull up that game in
just a moment here as we observe the
start of game four of this exhilarating
first SEC match okay here we go
so that occurred right around here right
Queen takes E5
and a foreign
and this is the kind of position that's
so hard to defend in a Time scramble
because black can torture you forever
with two pawns to the good and a little
bit later Robert he had to move Queen F1
infiltrating after Rook G3 Bishop E4 or
Knight E2 I think you're basically
checkmated
yikes yeah that was a big opportunity he
did only have about five seconds on his
clock so we understand why it happened
but you absolutely need to put those
games away and as we get into this game
here uh game five of the match Donya
white has expanded on the king side that
looks good but the problem is the king
side is now closed and that may not seem
like a big deal but normally when you've
gained a ton of space when you're
heading development you want to attack
and how do you attack you make Pawn
breaks here it's not going to be so easy
for white to do that so black is
actually doing okay despite the weird
opening I would say that black is even
doing more than okay I mean I'm maybe
I'm jumping the gun here and being a
little too pessimistic but I really
dislike the way that that Fabi has
handled This Modern Robert am I am I
missing something it just seems like
black is better black is better because
Black's next bunch of moves are also
very obvious Knight C6 and at some point
you can just take on D4 put a knight on
E5 and this is the issue where White's
pawns on G5 and H4 you want to play F4
that makes E4 loose in the G4 Square so
they're just drawbacks everywhere in
White's position that said proving the
advantage here for black maybe not the
easiest thing in the world yeah white is
still solid and I think Fabi is going to
try to complete his development quickly
maybe play Knight H3 and a big question
for white here from a defensive
standpoint is where do you want to
Castle my intuitive idea is to Castle
kingside I feel like castle and queen
side uh when you've got no attack going
on the other side of the board is is way
too dangerous but I don't know maybe you
keep your king in the center for the
time being
you've already made one incorrect Castle
call so let's see if this one is uh
better but it's a difficult question
you're right you're right my bad sorry
buddy I did not mean to put that again
but I go for one I think I've been to a
bad start in this it's just not easy to
realize where the King goes because
castle and queen side it already looks
dangerous their pawns sticking out in A4
the queen on C7 Bishop on G7 all those
pieces ready to attack uh but F4 was
played so what is fabi's actual idea is
he gonna keep pushing his pawns do you
want to play Knight F3 next Knight F3
seems logical but then E4 feels a bit
tender as well and look at Arjun going
for the queen side and if you have to
play the move B3 you open up the long
diagonal that Bishop on G7 is going to
become even more of a beast and unlike
the previous game in the Sicilian game
Bishop H6 is obviously a absolute pipe
dream I mean for that to be possible you
know the world will have to change
there was a movie you liked in an
earlier game where black played E5 and
at some point I feel like there could be
an E5 move for origin just trying to
carve out the D4 Square the big issue
for White's Pawn structure is in part as
you were mentioning the Bichon G7 has
the full scope of the diagonal but on
top of that you can't compete for the
dark squares in the center and that was
a big decision by origin to take that
huge decision and very very committal
you can't go back from that now the idea
seems to be to soften White's control of
the D4 Pawn but he's not winning D4
White's got enough Defenders he's
training everything but has Arjun
properly thought through the
consequences of this trade who benefits
no he is I'm not sure it's black takes
an A5 that's the key thing he missed he
saw all this he saw the queen trade he
said I have dark Square domination and
if you could play Rook takes you have
and pawn A5 for black at the same time
black is doing great but look at Fabi he
immediately senses the moment A6 and B4
are split and just like bowling that's
not a good thing because B4 is harder to
protect if A4 A6 is a hard Defender
Bishop E2 right now this is a big moment
for Fabiano where he played a terrible
opening and now he does have a good
position and this is what these games
come down to at this level you're not
exaggerating if black could have played
A5 let me make an example move Rook F2
A5 black is chilling he's gonna Castle
he's gonna go Rook C8 black and not lose
this in a million years as it stands the
landscape of the queen side changes
completely that pawn on A6 is a
long-term weakness that is what the
difference is composed of and that
separates players in individual games at
the highest level so right now Bobby is
doing the right thing and considering
his options Rook A4 is very tempting the
simple Rook F2 is possible Bishop E2
going after A6 so which Pawn do you want
to go after he chooses A6 I think that's
the best decision and if you play Knight
B8 here white plays Bishop C4 blocking
The Rook on C5 as it attack attempts to
take the pawn C2 and instead ours just
Castle so if he takes A6 he wants Rook 8
and taking on A5
okay so Fabi where is he gonna put his
Bishop did Carolina maybe Rush the move
Bishop takes A6 maybe that was the time
to play Bishop C4 or Rook A4 and just
preserve the weakness on A6 until until
you've found a way to secure your A5
Pawn now I think Arjun might be out of
the woods again
is Fabby trying to
squeeze through F5
or maybe even E5 yeah he's just giving a
few difficult options Knight B6 takes
care of both you attack that Bishop on
C4 so Bishop D3 the good news for Fabi
is he has everything defended right the
opponency two is never going to be under
attack with the bishop on D3 the bad
news for Fabi is he doesn't really have
a plan right no F5 I don't think so then
I can even go up to D7 E5 later that
looks very bad E5 is just losing a pawn
so there's no real idea for white
yeah I mean unless you can guarantee
that the move F5 allows you to get
through to the F7 Pawn or infiltrate
that square giving up the E5 Square in
such a position is Unthinkable and I
don't know if Arjun has an active plan
either maybe he could try to reposition
his Rooks properly on the queen side
what you don't want to do if you're
black Robert is give up control of the a
file because if white gets gets control
of the a file eventually white could you
know uh surround his tentacles around
the B4 Pawn and actually now that you
say that at some point a move that E5
can still be possible if you want to get
a rook to the fourth rank not with that
black knight getting a D5 so quickly but
I would give up some of the king side
pawns to get before and then go for an
outside pass Pawn easier said than done
I'm aware but I'm just keeping those
ideas in the back of my mind
yeah great Point King G7 by Arjun just a
little bit of main maintenance on his
position improving the placement of his
King getting out of the potential pin
along the a2j8 diagonal and Fabi kind of
moves along the same line centralizing
his own Monarch okay the player is
finally taking a little bit of a breath
and I'm kind of into fabi's position a
little bit I know every move will
probably say zeros but the reason why is
the side that controls the pawn breaks
is often the side with the advantage I
don't think that black should touch any
of his pawns I think they're good where
they are and Fabi can make improving
moves King E3 uh maybe play a move like
Rook F2 and just you know just little
moves here and there and make Black's
life a little bit more difficult that
said even if you give white four free
turns that are not resulting in a
Checkmate I don't see what the actual
plan is in whoa I was just saying black
should not move pawns he plays D5 and
already the eval bar is not happy with
that decision another very committal
call and obviously the ideal scenario
for black is if Fabby plays E5 which I'm
pretty sure he's not going to do after
E5 E6 the king side is permanently
locked up and black is just
strategically winning here but instead
Fabi says hey I don't have to move my
e-pawn it's well defended he brings this
King up to E3 and who benefits in the
event that the Center opens up well
let's wait for two reasons Robert first
of all the bishop usually benefits in
such situations but second of all the
Rook has easy access to the D4 square
and there goes the B4 Pawn Yeah the king
D4 if the Rooks get traded that King has
easy access over to the queen side and
if you open the D file Here Comes Rook
D4 as you're mentioning if you don't
open the D file at some point white
consider the move F5 let's go F5 and
maybe F6 check open up some lines here
for White's pieces I really didn't like
the move D5 but I also didn't really see
what black should have been doing
well maybe he that's exactly the answer
he shouldn't have been doing anything
just Rook A7 basically waiting around
for white to demonstrate ways to improve
his position you called it F5 is on the
board and maybe Arjun should try to
close the position up again and then try
to get his Knight over to E5 but after d
for King F4 Knight D7 Rook A1 you were
talking about control in the a file I
mean just feels like maybe black is just
in time as he tries to control the a
file and the E5 square but it's a close
call but it's still a three result game
you could Envision a scenario I think
where black gets his Knight to E5 gets
control of the a file and suddenly white
might start feeling uncomfortable again
Knight D7 is on the board I actually
think this was an excellent last two
moves by Arjun I'm with you that Knight
coming to E5 is scary although if you
play 95 too soon white plays F6 gets a
rook on F6 that Rook starts roving
around the sixth rank going after the
pawn so Knight E5 that looks like a
pretty obvious move and what is the
plays F6 yeah but okay he plays GTA
accepts another big decision now Fabby
saddled with all sorts of weaknesses on
the king side he's obviously going for
the initiative but that night on E5 it's
such a beast because it's both a
defensive and obviously an attacking
piece and if you play Bishop D5 here
there might just be the move Rook A2 uh
that looks like a problem for white If
you defend C2 hey there's D3 check in
the air so Rook takes C2 is possible and
the F6 Pawn is likely going to be a
goner
and Rook takes D4 if I be parting ways
with a c Pawn but now after Rook C3 the
situation just looks nastier than ever
for white and this is where argent's at
his best I think Fabi looked at the
match score felt he needed to win this
game Arjun never does that he is so
stoic when it comes to his chest he's
not taking unnecessary gambles and this
is actually looking like it's going to
be another win for Archen at this point
it most certainly is and and the move D5
it was a committal decision by Arjun but
it was in a wild risk he knew that his
position was still fundamentally sound
can he drive this game home Rook takes
B3 a little tactics there oh but it
ain't over after Bishop takes B3 maybe
the bishop can come back to D5 and you
can somehow try to entrap Black's pieces
in the center right King E3 King F4 is
on its way King the Knight out of E5 the
F7 Pawn cannot be dropped that is not a
pawn you want to give up in 20 seconds
he plays B3 great move Rook B1 and
what's his follow-up he's just giving
away the pawn Rook P4 maybe trade pieces
and if you give away the pawn there's
gonna be a mating that on B8 before you
know it I think takes in G5 is the best
winning chance oh very good chance you
just win see Fabi holding this
King F6 King F4
ah oh and Arjun just can't move his King
because of that darn F7 Pawn that's
right you know maybe he is holding it
King G7 back but there's always a move
like Bishop D1
well the ideal setup is F6 and then
bring the king back to G5 and then I
feel like Black's gonna win
somehow the evil bar showing zeros
so King H6
Bishop C8 okay
um this is looking scary I don't care
what the eval Bar says oh it's looking
very scary but how is black gonna make
progress at some point Robert you
probably have to push the spawn to H3
and he just grabs his head he can't
believe it he just gave away the pawn
it's still not totally over
it's looking pretty bad but I guess if
the evil bar only says minus whatever
that is three oh now it's over right
Knight F3
okay but where exactly do you get your
knight to
whoa whoa wait oh Bishop takes
what he had a move there for one second
not sure what it was now I have four
wins I have three in come the Pawns
and that wait King G3 apparently was a
draw he just hasn't touched his King G3
still again he missed like eight times
what the heck was that now King he won
black wins he just never looked at
moving his King I think he felt like he
was lost and he just was he stopped
thinking essentially he was just making
moves and Arjun made him pay so this is
a two-point lead for argentera gaisy but
Dania that was a missed chance for
Fabiano to save that half Point as we
head in to the break between uh two
players I mean I can show this really
quickly I think he just lost hope as a
matter of fact Robert if we look at this
uh coldly after King G3 it's just an
insta drop black is in zuzwang look at
this position if you move the king you
drop the F Pawn if you move the Knight
you drop the h-bond there's no way for
the Knight to intercept The Bishop's
control of F1 King G3 was an immediate
draw but Fabi just mentally dejected
after he blundered that second Pawn he's
down by two points he needs to do some
TLC and come back in the second half of
this five minute portion yeah the break
could not come at a better time for him
it is halfway through the longest time
people hear The Opening match of the
speed test Championship Don and I will
be right back for more action between
five on a carwana and Arjun aragaisi in
just a few
[Music]
check out chess.com's newest mobile
release for Android and iOS now with
game review
game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play use
retry mistakes to get another shot at
finding missed opportunities
game review is available today on both
Android and iOS
download our app and try it yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
he is looking as stoic as ever and Donya
he a two-point lead for that man right
there it kind of looks like he might
even be trailing he just doesn't react
in a way that you'd expect not at all
you and Fabi I think in one of his
podcast episode mentioned that you
really can't judge chess players by
their body language you really can never
tell and I think Arjun is a great case
of that you literally cannot tell if
he's down by five or he's up by five as
it stands he is up by two points and
he's doing real well in this match thus
far right and as we check his insights
speed is a weapon of his I mean he
really does not lose by time very often
and we've seen that in this match when
it gets down to the wire he's able to
defend tough positions he's able to
execute good positions and he is the
2022 jscc Champion so Dania I mean that
just says it all oh it definitely does
the fact that he beat Nee Hall to get
there and we've seen that in the first
couple games of the match I mean it's
gotten down to a Time scramble virtually
every time and it's not like Fabi is
getting blown off the board I think if
your car wanna you don't need to make
any systemic changes to the way that
you're playing Bobby's playing fine the
games are really close he just has to be
a little bit more accurate in those
critical moments a little bit better in
time scrambles that's been the
difference thus far for sure and for
Fabi as you said he doesn't need to
reinvent the wheel as you've stated in
the past and so I feel like he needs to
go back with that Petrov it was a good
opening for him he also sacked that rook
in the corner earlier uh in the Italian
game it didn't work out for him he lost
in 15 moves but it was an adventurous
choice and instead we're getting a four
nights with H3 Arjun probably just
saying you know what let's avoid Theory
altogether I have the lead here if
you're gonna come back you need to start
winning some way somehow and now we have
a reverse this is even hard to say a
reverse four night Scotch with the pawn
sitting on H3 now that's got to be in
White's favor to some extent right
because I mean it covers the G4 score
and Bishop G4 is an integral part of
White's opening strategy in the fortnite
scotch
no it's a good point uh to make because
it is exactly it's hard to talk about
this no it is but you're right because
in the fortnite scotch there's often the
queen for weiken F3 the bishop to G5 so
with the pod on H3 you've already taken
care of that and we're getting this
exact variation so white should be
slightly for Choice Your Castle you play
D4 these are normal moves but Fabi you
know he has experience in these
positions so it shouldn't come as a
complete surprise
yeah and it's not like oh if black can't
get his light squared Bishop to G4 then
black is lost I mean you can get you can
put your Bishop on D7 that's not the end
of the world and big question for Arjun
I mean he doesn't have to play D4 for
his part and he doesn't he plays the
move D3 choosing to keep the center
closed I actually kind of like that
decision in the context of the fact that
Bishop G4 is impossible very positional
for Arjun he gives up the bishop another
committal decision yeah but it's not
like black has too much difficulty at
the moment those double isolated C pawns
they may seem like long-term issues but
you have an open file anytime you have
double pawns a file opens a rook V8
looks very natural here to me uh he
plays Bishop E6 first stopping any sort
of Knight C4 that also uh makes sense
but I I think you just got to bring a
rook to be make Queen C8 Queen A6 at
some moment just use what Avenues have
been open for you and there's a ticking
clock because if you give white the
chance to put his Bishop on B2 if white
can provoke the move F6 that's a pretty
serious King side weakness again nothing
we talk talk about is the end of the
world because both sides are incredibly
solid you know this is going to be a
long middle game but you don't want to
make unnecessary weaknesses and you want
to make it as difficult as possible for
your opponent to put their pieces on on
ideal squares and Fabi does just that
with your move Rook B8 I think we're
going to see some kind of like Rook B1
Rook B6 Rook B3 as both players Vibe for
the B flat but no we see Queen F3 that
makes sense of course you don't want to
give up the C6 Pawn I imagine so it'll
move like
Queen D7 or Bishop D7 no we play C5 is
that Bishop on D6 or just a big old pawn
you know what I say in such situations
don't you what do Bishops do uh they
actually in this case the pawns are also
bad so
yeah the E5 Pawn is pretty good at some
point he'll probably put F5 and maybe
even E4
true bad Bishops defend good puns I've
never said that before in a commentary
stream just like not Stephen Curry
references they're super original Oh I
thought I'd say they're cooking but you
know either way uh they do the job and
here I think white should go after the
C5 Pawn you mentioned bad pawns we
should attack them
Bishop B2 instead though so I feel like
Arjun he's playing good developing moves
he's not just getting sidetracked by
this Pawn on C5 he wants to keep his
position nice and sturdy and for fabi's
part that Bishop on E6 where really
wants to sit the prime real estate is on
the long diagonal so maybe bishop CA can
be considered here of course this also
has the effect of protecting the E5 Pawn
With The Rook Bishop C8 looks good maybe
Queen F6 that self pins the queen but it
ain't it isn't too easy for white to put
pressure on the E5 Pawn
Queen F6 plate good call by you and
there is E4 that white has to look out
for because the queen on F3 will be
under attack and the bishop on B2 will
be exposed to the queen F6 and that's
why Arjun he goes back to E2 with a
queen ideally he would have put rookie
two Rook a to E1 but with E4 available
there he he instead brings his Queen
back that's such an instructive line let
me show that really quickly rookie 2
runs into E4 the bishop is hanging lpdo
loose pieces drop off takes takes and
now both pieces are hanging at the same
time white ends up losing the bishop so
good call there Arjun drops his Queen
back to E2 and Fabi repositions his own
Queen to G6 using tactics to indirectly
defend the E5 Pawn I think Bishop E5
runs into Bishop takes C4 discovering
the attack on the E5 Bishop I like
Black's position now I mean you have the
strong Center and he played Bishop A3
and now is the time you go for an attack
because white piece is all distracted
over there on the queen side so I'm
already looking at the move F4 as a way
to go after H3 you could also play E4
that looks like it creates all sorts of
tactical possibilities for black opening
the bishop on D6 as well
E4 just leads to chaos and Anarchy and I
think Arjun probably would play you four
within like a couple of seconds but Fabi
of course he takes a more analytical
approach in these kinds of moments what
you want to avoid is spending you know a
minute and a half and you know putting
the sun cost into a move that you would
play anyway
and he plays Bishop D7 he's using your
plan though getting the bishop to Long
diagonal I like it
margin's probably going to gobble I mean
you don't put your pieces on B3 and A3
to not take on C5 but what he's
undoubtedly worried about is Bishop
takes C5 Bishop C6 threatening Checkmate
on G2 yeah it's just the main thread
stop making a mountain yeah not a big
deal but after F3 it might become a big
deal because E4 this is I believe what
we're gonna see that's terrifying great
call look at this position this looks
just to the naked eye this looks losing
for white
yeah but I guess it's not because of
maybe Queen G4 whoa but Bishop G3 now
let's keep the Bishop from the board
and then follow that up with E3 and open
up the other Bishop now maybe it can be
shut down with D5
but I feel like you want to keep more
pieces on the board with the attack and
the past Pawn so I'm looking at keeping
the bishop alive maybe Fabi realizes not
the end of the world but no he does Play
Bishop G3 step one and if you play Rook
F1
um you know the movie E3 as you
mentioned with that very strong
yikes and step three yeah drop the
bishop back and threaten the sack on H3
I mean that Bishop on t7 it isn't as
good as on the long diagonal Robert but
it it ain't too shabby either no and the
bishop he goes Bishop two check he's
probably worried about the E3 Pawn being
a little bit loose for the time being
and if your best bet is to sacrifice
enough too for Arjun I don't think you
have quite enough for the Rook you have
a knight and a couple pawns but black
also has the safer King I agree in
principle and I think black is still
better after Rook takes F2 but perhaps
it was a better decision to keep as much
potential energy in the position as
possible keeping the bishop on G3 would
have opened up more possibilities of for
example Bishop E5 and queen G3 now Bobby
kind of puts his eggs in one basket
Arjun I think there was no doubt in
anyone's mind that he was stacking on F2
no and after Bishop D7 H3 is hanging so
he plays King H2
um the Knight on B3 will likely go to D4
at some point so if C4 cannot be
attacked then origin is in pretty good
shape but look at that spicy what
recognition
Here Comes Rook B2 going after that C2
Pawn directly so I love the move A5 and
Fabi I love when these top players they
play on both sides of the board that I
think is one of the single most
difficult skills in all of chess the
recognition that you need to strike on
the side of the board that you really
haven't touched for the entire game
Arjun meets him at the top with A4 but
Robert now the Knight on B3 is seriously
loosened up it's only protected by the
C2 Pawn which is in turn defended by the
queen that is not a secure construction
and rookie 5 seems like the most random
move in the world to me but I look at
the Evo bar and it stays the same which
means the best move what a game this has
been from both sides of course 500 with
the advantage right now but arjun's
hanging in there and after Bishop D4 The
Rook is under attack on E5 if you play
Rook f8 thinking you're getting a Tempo
against the queen I believe Arjun will
immediately snap The Rook off on f8 then
snap The Rook off on E5 and say I have
now a minor piece a rook and two pawns
for the queen so that's why Rook F5 was
the choice instead black is better black
is calling the shots but this could turn
really really quickly I mean there is no
reason that Arjun won't gobble the pawn
on A5 on the next move and don't fall
asleep on the A4 Pawn I mean that pawn
will be on A7 in the blink of an eye
that is we've already seen Arjun used a
past a pawn uh not with decisive effect
because he did let the wind slip but he
has shown that it's going to be
difficult to counter so I think right
now Donna he needs to play Fabiano C6
you need to challenge white setup and by
playing C6 you're opening the board up
for the bishop on D7
instead he plays Rook f8 with the
infuriating thing is that the white
Bishop controls the F2 Square otherwise
the threat of Rook F2 would be instantly
decisive what is fabby's follow-up if
Arjun just grabs the pawn on A5 does he
want something like Rook G5 maybe Rook
H5 and a sack on H3 I mean it looks
terrifying for sure I really like that
Rook G5 idea and maybe Queen D6 first
and then Rook G5 but no matter what
there is going to be a sacrifice he does
take on April about to find out so Fabi
has a chance and we see the Evo bar
going down down down
and down down yeah I feel like your Rook
G5 idea is there I think first queen D6
then Rook G5 the queen can come into G3
all sorts of threats available oh the
Fabi is just he's on a roll this game
and he's finding every accurate move
Bishop takes H3 forces White's hand but
King H1 Robert might not actually solve
the problem I think Bishop takes H3
anyway just looks totally devastating
with this Knight in Timbuktu not
participating in the defense he can't
afford that when you're already down in
exchange to begin with it's the one
offside move Arjun has played maybe in
this entire match but definitely in this
game and it's going to cost him that is
the margin at this high level Rook G6 oh
sliding The Rook back H3 is still
hanging if King H1 Bishop A3 Rook F3
coming so it just feels like there is an
attack that is Raging on if you play C5
for white then the queen goes to G3
you're actually helping black execute
the attack
there's just no way to stop Queen G3 and
White's just not nearly fast enough on
the queen side arjun's clock is ticking
down he's now down 30 seconds last ditch
attempt C5 on the board but Queen G3
just looks completely devastating and if
the time to reverse I would give Arjun
some chances but not here nice move
though yes throwing 97 check you do not
want to fall for that four
do not take on H3 here I thought rookie
8 might have been the chance now Bishop
F4 smokes the queen out oh but where two
is a queen almost trapped H 95 yeah
Queen H3 is Knight E5 good call
and after 95 black has to give up the
exchange all of a sudden White's
defending I think Queen H4 but then
still 95. oh my God it's 10 seconds he
could even lose this game
oh absolutely 95 and then Bishop takes
H3 could have been met with G3 wait he
went King H2 and what is the deal here
he just takes on C6 so Bobby is trying
to avoid danger oh my God 20 seconds
though when Arjun could grab the pawn on
C7 oh my God he's turning this around
completely turn it around and probably
just works he's one second he barely got
that move on and there comes the a pawn
at long last and Rook A3 Rook G3 comes
to mind Black's King is caught on the
crossfire
it was Queen of A5 is hanging right oh
Rook G3
he lost Flags
oh my goodness and we mentioned this
earlier but Anish giri talked about this
in Toronto it was a really a type of
conversation that uh when Fabi gets into
real-time trouble down to seconds he
probably has maybe the lowest floor in
this event and that's the problem is
that uh you know he had chances there
and he just collapsed because he
couldn't handle the time pressure and
it's not that he's bad in time pressure
it's just that harjun is an absolute
Beast the way he produced chances there
the Turning Point Robert was when he
managed to get his Knight to E5 that
threat really just took Fabby out of his
comfort zone he was in an absolute role
prior to that what a heartbreaker this
is a tough build to swallow and now the
lead it's balloon to three and wow
that's a pretty big deal there's plenty
of time there's an eternity left in this
match but this is not going fabby's way
it isn't but there's nothing that can
brighten your day like playing the white
side of the French and right now a lot
of extra space for Fabi Arjun the best
news for him is he got rid of that light
Square Bishop by trading on A6 so
finally pushed his pawns forward will
bring his Rook up to H3 at some point
try to go for Rook lift
however he's got issues right the C2
Pawn the A3 Pawn typical in the French I
feel like Fabi is on the verge of
tilting he oh I was literally opening my
mouth to say the same thing I was going
to say maybe I'm influenced overly
influenced by the score of the match
rubber but it just feels like he's
floundering feels like he's grasping at
straws tilting at windmills no pun
intended
and he needs a little nasty here he
needs to turn this around
Arjun has got an ideal win our setup
here yeah something has gone very wrong
uh for fobby in this match overall and
in this game Queen takes C2 is available
for black but I wouldn't go upon
grabbing just yet and the last thing you
want to see for Arjun is with your King
on f8 and no development of your pieces
is this board to open up so he plays
Knight C6 a knight takes E5 is also a
threat which is why Queen F4 was playing
to put the queen on the defended Square
that's a great move by Fabby actually
and maybe it was worth developing the
other night first if you're Archer now
he grabs on C2 and he says Hey Pawn is a
pawn show me what you got Fabby wow he's
gonna go Bishop E3
oh it's just gonna go right after the C5
Pawn if indeed Arjun takes back so uh
showing tremendous understanding are
both players I'm just very confused
about what's happened here I'm looking
at Knight G to E7 for Arjun just to
develop my pieces I just don't trust the
King sitting there on f8 I don't want to
stay there forever
fun fact I'm oh and three in the in the
French uh that's my lifetime score and
one of those games was against Fabi in
the 2017 us Championship I played this
exact line with black but Arjun is
handling this with just a little bit
more finesse than yours truly well the
Queens are off the board now that's just
a bad ending for white you see the pawn
on A3 and C3 are both weaknesses but
with the move Rook H4 if white can just
slide on over to the queen side look at
Black's lack of development I actually
think that this is a position with
chances for both sides for sure oh most
definitely even with the Queen's off the
board you're right black has to find a
way to untangle his kingside and Arjun
playing with fire there but also playing
with Tempo getting his night out to F6
The Rook probably will shift to D4 and
after Knight C5 it does look like the
worst is behind him he will be exactly
one move away Robert from fully
consolidating his pieces right so father
needs to act quickly H5 is also hanging
so if black is not threatened in any way
Knight takes H5 just scoop upon and
that's the problem with White's position
black has one weakness the pawn on B6
and I guess let's call a second weakness
with the King on f8 uh just in the Rooks
way but white has A3 C3 and H5 all to
worry about this is bad news for Fabi
and Arjun is just having his way right
now
and if you have to play a move like Rook
H4 that's just not a good sign but it
makes sense you can't just start giving
away random pawns you earn an end game
at this point but this gives Arjun the
necessary Tempo to complete the
consolidation of his pieces A4 there by
Fabi trying to fix the weakness on B6
which might actually be the only Target
in this position that white can easily
attack
yes and it's a good move I think Knight
C5 it looks threatening but there's a
rook in H4 don't forget about it it
defends that pawn A4 in addition to the
Rook sitting there on A1 so Fabi uh he
goes Rook B1 getting out of any
potential pins everything is defended
but black can do the same oh and C4 Rook
takes A4 that Rook on H4 hanging
wow that's actually in The Rook D4 there
maybe if that gets Tactical
that does get let me show this on the
board
C4 which is exactly what Fabi is
calculating now the bad piece of news is
that Arjun could just drop his Knight
back to F6 and say I don't care Rook B6
or K4 I'm fine but after Rook a four
Rook D4
night before
this doesn't seem like the kind of
position Arjun wants out of this end
game but if there's C3 there's no clear
way to punish it then it might be worth
investigating
and well he is about to investigate it
because C4 is on the board big moment
here
is Arjun gonna snap that pawn off on A4
and go for that chaotic line that we
just looked at well the downside of
playing Knight F6 which was your first
instinct is that B6 does fall so even if
you get A4 we're just trading off some
pawns maybe the winning chins aren't
great but if you look at the match score
Arjun doesn't need to take any risk to
win this game because he's ahead and he
does the right thing I think from a
match perspective Knight F6 was the best
move it probably was also the best move
in the position uh so great choice by
our generic IC agree completely and one
thing I'm noticing uh in this five
minute portion Robert is how quickly
Arjun tends to make decisions in
critical moments I mean I could see
somebody taking 15 20 minutes in an over
the board game calculating work takes A4
I could see somebody taking two minutes
in a Blitz game instead Arjun he's put
the accent on keeping the time advantage
and just tossing the ball continuously
back into Fabio's Court trusting his
instincts and it's resulted in just wild
success thus far although now this
results in an outside pass Pawn for
Fabiano so after King back to e or f8
I'm not sure where it should go the
bishop slides back to E1 and the worst
is behind white like there were these
weak pawns now everything's defended and
you have a pawn A4 defended by a knight
uh the bishop on E1 is eyeing that A5
square if the Knight moves out the way
to push the pawn so I feel like the
worst is behind Fabi and Arjun continues
to Blitz out his moves trying to find
the best possible squares for his Knight
it's a three result game I mean I can
see this going either way I could see
white losing control over the game if
Black's Knight jumps into D3 maybe Fabi
will lose his H Pawn and so all hands on
deck for white defending the D3 Pawn
with the King
wow and King E2 just uh bringing the
King as a active piece in the ending The
Rook on H4 can slide towards the king's
Queen side excuse me at some point they
work to B4 but H5 remains a Target so
I'm not sure if you should ever move
that Rook but I don't like being
Tethered to a pawn
and what I also don't like is the way
that White's Rooks kind of appear
discombobulated black threatens rook
ac-8 and if the Knight moves away from
C3 the floodgates open The Rook
infiltrate C2 and you could absolutely
get mated in a position like this it's
true so maybe Rook H to B4 is the way to
go give up H5 trade a pair of Rooks on
B8 and say that your outside pass Pawn
should prove good compensation for the
pawn deficit agreed I think Rook before
is the practical decision and again look
at that clock fabby's clock creeping
down to one minute and all before you
know it arjun's up 90 seconds
look how quickly he takes on H5 wait
then there's Rook B5 that I saw the eval
bar go up like why would it go up rook
B5 B5 skewers the knights viewers the
knights and after F6 there's he missed
it both Players missed it
it is helpful to have the eval bar but
the knights were in the same row but
Fabi has to see that the knights on the
same row both of them undefended I'll
show this on the board Rook B5 F6 and at
the very least you have F4 you also have
G4 simply trapping the other night this
one a piece
okay well missed opportunity but if we
look at the game down here the outside
pass Pawn that is very dangerous now you
move the Knight out the way to A4 let's
say the knight's trying to come into C5
so I believe that Bobby should not
really be in huge risk right now if he
can also just deliver a bunch of checks
if the King goes to the back rank so I
feel like he should be in good shape to
hold this one despite that oversight
agreed it it almost seems like Arjun is
trying to flag him but now the Indian
Grandmaster taking his time realizing
that white is like too tempy away from
shoving the stroke off of A6 and you
cannot let this Pawn reach A7 Knights
are notoriously bad at stopping corner
passers so you know the Rook is going to
do the hard work here wow on King D6 so
F4 the night might go back to D7 uh
something like that just to close off
the seventh rank but he plays Knight A4
he wants Bishop B4 check at some point
I'm afraid the clock is going to decide
this game again
he's gotta move his Rook
Rook he's gonna move period
maybe I'll go over B1 just keep the Rook
away from the enemy King he does just
that Knight D5 looks pretty good
creating a night cover of course if
you're black do not move your king back
to D7 no
for obvious reasons
Rook see one check you want to play King
D6 but then Knights that's why he put
the Knight on D5 whoa
okay
Knight C3 trade the knights aha take
with the bishop for sure
and you can always take oh and now G7
hangs right if F6 you can always take on
E5 I think and make a draw but I don't
know if Bobby's playing for more right
now I think that's the likely outcome in
F6 you're still down a minute on the
clock
maybe arjun's gonna move his Knight and
play for more but that nah oh and he
does wow Bishop G7 what's Bobby thinking
about Rook A5 okay still should be a
draw all right I'll take on H6 just
worried I'm just worried fabby's gonna
miss a fork he's got 15 seconds 95
Knight G4 is scary it really is 95 is a
great move right now and it's played
I think I'll play rookie one or
something very solid
white is not out of the woods though
King C4 and E5 E4 Knight E5 to F3
they're all sorts of uh tricks and
threats that you need to watch out for
I've seen Arjun squeeze these positions
out so many times
E5 just push that pawn E4
so far so good for Fabi but he's running
out of air for his pieces oh that was a
good move because if E4 there's King F4
he wants to run after the F5 Pawn
oh great call oh that's actually a very
solid defensive construction when he
moves this King back okay E4 for sure
definitely but he attacks the bishop
first I think he's testing fabi's Mouse
speed that's why he's attacking the
bishop he's saying does Fabi have that
quickness or is it costing him like 0.5
seconds every time
and that Knight can jump to D3 I mean
Arjun is a million ways to torture him
here I like the way fabi's defending
thus far he hasn't missed a fork he's
kept his Bishop solid Now The Rook
defends the bishop and King F1 important
move there and watch out for like 92 to
F3 in a back rank Checkmate like you
have to be so careful here if your
father that's actually a massive threat
foreign
Knight H2 looks very tempting
although with the King on G2 there is
actually no easy way to Checkmate the
king because the King has H3 and G2 as
Escape squares it's true so for Knights
two Knight F3 is like Rook f8 going
after the F5 pawn and then things can
turn around
I mean Arjun also milking the overall
match clock
oh he trades there rookiechu he gets in
a rook end
83. oh gosh G4 gotta push that pawn
still scary but looks like the worst is
behind him
yeah and I think there's no way to kick
the king out of F1 sure still not easy
King F3 but long side good good
technique from Bobby Rook check back to
F5
um
King F4
I would keep trying
and he goes over here the pawn is not
you can't push it for black that's the
problem
and here comes still trying
I think he's doing what you said he's
just milking the mesh clock
but now you've got the side checks as
you indicated no this is a draw
I mean every last resource exhausted
don't go King F5 after Rook A6 yeah yeah
we'll see a rook trade and then trade
does Argent play it out that's the
question
I would not pre-move here
I think certain people
yeah this one's fine he'll handle it
go ahead hold for Fabi he could not have
afforded to lose that game he just
couldn't no the tide was turning against
him and now we see uh in English from
Arjun and a quick check on B4 solid
response I think this is gonna be
arjun's match strategy from now on why
does he need to take any risk he doesn't
need to play openings with tactical
melees just play solid chess and Fabi
has not proven that he can beat origin
thus far no and you're absolutely right
he's up three points he says hey you
know I'm I think I'm in better form uh
I'm more than happy to get an equal
position out of the opening every time
and he's playing totally unambitiously
with white here
and I guess the question is where is he
going to develop his light squared
Bishop he's going to go G3 then maybe
Fabi can grab the center with C6 and D5
I think black could consider c65 anyway
Robert White has to be a little careful
I kind of hated the movie E4 because now
I'm looking at F5 at some point for
black
yeah the side that controls the pawn
breaks is off on the side with the
advantage and here okay the D5 Square
you need to keep an eye on uh but like
Knight E8 and F5 is just an idea that's
coming to mind what a weird opening we
just said so many like random pawn moves
and there was H6 about what does that do
preventing Queen D2 to G5 no I I just
feel like that was a careless move and
I'm not saying that black is worse I
don't think so I think fabi's playing
very good chess but I those little
decisions I feel like that's what's
costing Fabi in this match is he he's
not pouncing when the moment is there
you're absolutely right and Arjun
executing a very typical maneuver for
really all English positions that night
from F3 to he won a C2 to E3 eventually
to D5 and so Fabi strikes with B4
forcing White's hand and I think e takes
D5
is generally the way people recapture
here now he goes CD okay and here comes
the Knight to C3 this is bad for white I
don't like CD at all this is really bad
well the only chance is to strike at the
king side but here comes the Knight but
the problem for white right if you play
F5 hoping to get an F6 Black's obviously
gonna see that he plays F6 and he
stopped it right and later in the game
black could try to think about G6 but
now there's no need because white is
very slow and look at A4 it's happening
so quickly over here it is but but so is
white preparing G5 it doesn't take all
that many moves I mean you think about
it one two three and you're ready to
play G5 so I'm not totally pessimistic
about White's King side chances here
yeah but there's the petrogen King march
right King F7 King yay King D7 just
bring your king over there I didn't like
A4 for that reason I think they first
should have taken care of his king
um but I also tend to trust Fabi with
big decisions and Knight D4 now that's
very good without the D4 Square what is
Arjun doing here
I'm not I don't want to answer that I
feel like he's played a great match thus
far but this game has been very shaky
which is uncharacteristic of the
Superstar teenager oh goodness just
ripping the position and let's not
forget D3 is hanging so if you ever have
to move your queen away like if a b
takes A2 and you stick with a queen down
goes D3 if you put a B3 here Knight
takes B3 is a simple Fork uh the Kings
on F2 which means that the open B file
is probably bad news for the white king
this is starting to look not pleasant at
all for Arjun no Argent is just sort of
I mean you could tell in the opening he
was playing a little carelessly but now
he's waltzed himself into a borderline
lost position can he pull a rabbit out
of the Hat this would be a huge win for
Fabby guess what if he wins this game in
under eight minutes he gets a game with
the white pieces he wins that one it's a
one point match and that's how quickly
these seemingly insurmountable uh winds
can can move at the drop of a hat and
this looks just incredible for fun look
at this clock by the way he has nearly
premium of four minutes he's pre-moving
he has D3 under attack he's doing Rook F
to B8 to go to B2 A4 is the extra Pawn
not long for this board this is a
terrible position for Arjun and this is
why I called it uncharacteristic we've
seen throughout the match he has played
a very solid style he has figured out
when fabi's you know coming from him
he's figured out a way to fend off the
initial threat and then also
seize control of the game even from that
point like the game where he went Knight
takes A5 and it was kind of dicey for
him so I just feel like this is really
an odd game for Arjun with a three-point
lead that said the game's not over Rook
takes D3 even if the material causes
white some problems uh but with the
threat of G5 at some point with white
trying to take over the B file maybe he
has hopes uh to survive this game
yeah I mean Arjun is a magician nihal is
a magician everybody from that
generation is a magician so Fabi he
cannot take his foot off the gas pedal
he also cannot fall behind too much on
the clock he's been doing a great job of
that thus far this game and look at Fabi
he doesn't even I don't need the D3 Pawn
that pawn ain't going anywhere I want
the B file instead oh
what Bishop takes D3 it's over goodbye
Queen B7 coming to theaters near you
um what just happened in this game this
was a horrendous game for Arjun Queen B7
Robert and C4 C3 you can actually resign
I I
I'm like looking at him just to see if
there's any changing body language the
good news for Arjun is he simply just
doesn't react and look at Bobby he's
stretching he's like all right now I'm
starting to feel it I'm getting my first
dub uh this is just completely hopeless
at this point isn't Knight E2 to C3 uh a
fork at the very least or Bishop B2 just
win material I think Bishop E2 would
force resignation as would 92 Knight C3
you you win a full piece with Bishop B2
I like that better
it's on the board
that's it wow
unreal
and it was self-induced and this was a
very surprising and for Fabiano just
what he needed he's getting that last
game in the five plus one time Patrol he
gets the white pieces and now another
Sicilian so will we see a bishop B5
check with Knight D7 no Bobby going for
main lines I think Fabi senses this is a
big chance for him and a dragon for
Arjun so fabi's saying full steam ahead
I'm going all in I want to win this game
and reduce this lead down to one
we have a Mainline dragon ladies and
gentlemen don't say that every day
no we don't and I mean this is a tried
and true opening B6 uh-huh I mean how
many games are in this position like
just no this is such a well-known line
but white is better here there is no
dispute the white is better in this line
and I also feel like stylistically it's
the type of position that Fabi likes
because you look at these long-term
weaknesses A7 and C6 for black simple
development for white
um I have never been a fan of this
opening from the black side but then
again I I'm nowhere near an expert and
arjun's playing at lightning speed
and some guy named Anish Geary uh don't
know much about him but he did make a
course on the dragon and he breathed a
little bit of fire into this system no
pun intended but nonetheless I mean
fundamentally if you look at Black's
Queen side structure Robert I mean you
can try for activity you can try for A5
A4 there's Dynamic chances but I mean it
just looks so nasty from a strategic
stand from a tactical standpoint that
Bishop aiming at F7 right Queen E3 just
bringing the queen towards and Jake
really Riley Queen E7 what's the
what's the rub
95. okay that does make sense so G4
first
good move by Fabi 95 anyway don't take
it with a bishop oh I was wondering at
95 isn't that just lose oh no Bishop D5
Queen takes C2 as checkmate
and where is White gonna put his Queen
is he gonna drop it back to D2 and force
an end game
because the bishop on F5 is nowhere good
to go is your claim
that's exactly my claim but Argent is
clearly studied this so maybe we just
have to give him credit he has clearly
prepped this out because he has barely
spent any time and you don't play these
kind of risky moves unless you've
studied your openings yeah that's
absolutely right and you can obviously
take more Liberties in a blitz match I
mean you can get a position that's
objectively worse that you wouldn't
think about playing in a classical game
but Queen D2 back now Fabby plays Queen
D2 so who does the pawn on E5 actually
favor
it's hard to say
so Bishop E6
I just goes after D5 Pawn
black does have this idea Robert of
playing H5 and creating a past Pawn
that's on tap but you don't want to rush
it because then you let up losing the H
Pawn right because E5 is hanging and the
H file Pawn will be a ice and isolated
one can't be protected so right now is a
big moment for Arjun he has prepped to
this point he plays King G7 so if we
just see a trade on E6 Rook takes E5
we're seeing some liquidation maybe some
decent chance for origin to hold but
when you have a queen side majority like
Fabiano does you have to keep thinking
the back your mind I have those
long-term chances but I'm gonna go on an
Alum here and say that I'm actually
concerned about White's position I'm
really really concerned that H5 is going
to come and white species kind of stuck
as they are on the queen side might not
be well equipped to handle the progress
of this pawn and that pawn goes really
fast
yeah I'm now concerned about it as well
and if Rook takes E5 King F6 is the idea
from Arjun he's bringing his King out
it's the end game let's get active and
then H5 rook h8 and so on so I'm with
you there and that's why Bobby's sitting
and thinking maybe he wants to uh take
on E6 he's not sure about it maybe he
wants to play the move G5 the pawn E5
can't be defended and G5 at least will
not give black an outside pass pawn and
I think you can combine those moves if
we pull up an analysis for Knight takes
C6 F takes C6 G5 deep freezing blacks
kingside Pawns of course the idea that
after H5 there is the end peasant G
takes H6 and as long as white prevents
black from making that passer white can
safely try to exploit his Queen side
majority G5 the immediate G5 is on the
board good call and Fabi not afraid of
that Bishop remaining Bishop F5 you can
just take on D5 first then take on E5
and black is saddled with an isolated
Pawns in two different places and that's
not good news so great move I would say
from Fabiano and if he ends up coming
back in this match sure the previous
game was important but that move G5 just
as you were saying you're starting to
get worried about five minutes position
he makes his move G5 and I think both of
us done it you know don't mean to speak
for you but now we're like wait a sec
this is starting to look very pleasant
no it absolutely is and this is why Fabi
is so good right G5 is a move that you
could easily glance over if you're
looking at the game quickly but if Fabby
wins this game then this was the reason
why right he prevents H5 he stops
arjun's counter play and he allows
himself to focus on his superiority on
the other side of the board
and that's the thing with apology follow
this you're you're one Pawn is kind of
stopping two and on the other side
eventually the pawns will get rolling so
what's the move here for Arjun I would
say Bishop F5 I mentioned don't really
like it
um is there a plan like can you still
play H6 and just try to get your king
active that probably loses definitely
try but
yeah gh6 and rookie five and how are you
gonna keep your minor pieces together in
the center without losing a pawn bishop
F5 is played
and you're exactly right he takes D5
takes D5 and Rook d8 might be a sad
necessity here for Arjun you can't give
up another queen Side Pawn so rookie
seven of course comes to mind just King
D2 bringing the king out
um you would love to go Knight D4 in one
turn he plays B4 why not let's expand
and protect the Knight
um I would say practically speaking what
do you think white wins this position 80
of the time maybe 70 80 of the time yes
and I think Super unpleasant I mean from
a practical standpoint H6 I think is is
Derek or you have to create some
traction on the king side or else you're
just gonna get stomped on the other side
of the board King have faith though
Arjun taking the passive approach King
D2 what's next for black that's what I'm
trying to figure out H6 was the only way
to open things up and now for King D2
I'm just failing to see individual moves
for black and step one for Fabi
successful he goes Rook D6 okay A4 let's
keep pushing slow I think he wants F6 I
mean at this point Arjun
is happy to part ways with this Depot
but look how prophylactically plays Fabi
F4 and I think he might actually move
his Rook back to keep the pawn on G5
freezing black king side majority
brilliant because he could have taken on
F6 and try to if Rook takes a take on D5
but said he says your pawns are stuck in
place my one takes care of your two Rook
A3 becomes a threat all of a sudden
you're gonna lose that a pawn which you
cannot afford to drop so
ah super unpleasant right now Arjun is
one move away from losing I really like
the move Rook B6 I think he had to try
that and the point is that by inducing
A3 you're actually preventing White's
Rook from swinging to A3 the pawn on A7
stays safe for the time being white
still doesn't have a passer on the queen
side so let's not pretend you know that
this game is over Fabby still needs to
handle this with a lot of finesse to
convert this into an actual point
right no Rook B6 is an important D4 Big
Choice putting his Pawn on a dark Square
so I'm not going to be projected by the
bishop just move that Rook away and the
bishop is controlling the light scores I
think Arjun is saying he has something
resembling a fortress here
I'm not sure if I believe in that but I
think yeah
I think white can even play C3 at some
point like if you take on C3 King takes
and go A4 and start pushing your king
Side Pawn excuse me Queen side pawns uh
and black cannot do the same that's the
really important part of having this
Pawn on G5 is the H Pawn can't go to H5
you take on poisson or n peasant as you
said so I just think that White's task
of pushing the pawn up the board is much
easier and something I always like to
point out Robert when there's only one
open file on the board the side that
controls it holds a major asset this
e-file it might not seem significant but
guess what the King on that f8 is firmly
stuck in place anytime you play King G7
The Rook infiltrate C7 and there is the
past pawn it has been made and it is
going to be pushed and we've talked
about how Bishops dominate Knights this
Knight dominates that Bishop it's on a
dark Square can't be attacked all
squares on the light you know E6 E4 D7
Etc are covered with Knight C5 so King
C4 is next followed by B5 and that pawn
is going up the board the one small
concern is if Arjun manages to take the
G5 Pawn off the board then he'll be able
to give up his Bishop for the B Pawn but
fabby's not going to give up a G5 Pawn
without a major fight no and King C4
step one I think this is the moment
where Fabi he calculates a little bit
too much because Arjun would have been
playing this last turn in three seconds
and then Fabi will spend 20 seconds and
then he'll get himself in time trouble
he may still win this game but I think
in the bigger picture that's what often
hurts him
that move surprises me a little bit I
thought King C4 and B5 was more
straightforward instead he moves his
Rook away from uh one open file to
another but he's giving Arjun a chance
to activate his King I don't like the
way Fabius handled this in the last
couple moves I don't like it either King
E5 to F4 looks very tempting maybe Rook
H4
yeah barely keeping that King out of
there and Arjun is down the clock down
50 seconds right now he needs to
continue the stubborn defense I still
think fabby's winning chances exceed
black strong chances but Arjun look at
him go activating his Rook once again
trying to go from the from the back side
and I think he's gonna try to win this
Jeep on yes but King D4 here let's
centralize that King and that allows you
to play B5 he goes King C4 instead
similar idea Rook a will be the main one
for black and how does that B Pawn get
pushed not now because rooksy won't
check that loses the Knight the Knight
is no good square is that Bishop under
five is suddenly the one dominating the
Knight Robert it was the other way
around when the position was more closed
now the bishop is the one controlling
important back uh retreating squares for
the night at night on C5 actually
becomes a bit of a liability well here
comes the king up to B5 so if you're a
rook G1 are you in time that King might
even go up to B6 or A6 and the B Pawn
gets pushed Knight B7 check also on the
docket origin down to 30 seconds he
plays Rook B1 just saying no King B6 for
you
he's kind of taking a middle approach
for now he stops the progress of the
pawn this is going to be another time
scramble you're right I think Fabi has
taken a little bit too long here both
sides down to 30 seconds it's a 50 50
game and Fabby brings his Rook back to
H2 setting up a potential check but in
comes arjun's King so if Rook F2 to keep
the king out of f4 is there King D4 King
E3 Here Comes oh goodness oh my gosh and
King A5 if King C3 is Knight A4 okay
and then Knight moves in B5 can you get
away with it wow B6 King E5 he has H4 to
keep the pawn protected that's very
important so Argentina under 15 seconds
he goes Rook G1
B5 now
you have to and he finally eliminates
the pawn
okay so what's going on here
should be a draw a lot of forks Rook D2
and King C6 maybe wow he trades Rooks no
he realized that he could trade Rook the
bishop will sacrifice up for that pawn
so Rook F2 back by Fabi Knight A6 I
think black's not worse anymore I agree
is happening
I could see this going wrong for what I
mean King E3 Bishop E4 White's got to be
careful with that g Pawn advancing
pretty soon
okay so this should be four
Rook G5 oh there's no king of 496 check
so you can play Rook G5 but five seconds
oh my gosh he's on G5 here comes the
pawn oh my God I'm getting concerned
white could lose this one second move
what just happened he flew did he just
forget about his time
but that just cannot happen you can't
lose a game like this
and like
look at Arjun it's like he doesn't even
know the game's over he is not
celebrated he is not like why is he
moving yeah he's he's sitting there
waiting for the next move and that is
inexcusable if you want to win a
speeches championship match Donya you
cannot flag in that position
yeah I mean draw okay Arjun defended
like a beast but hey you drive the game
you're still down by two points you just
can't leave points on the side of the
road like this and this destroys all of
the momentum that he built up in the
previous game the lead is back to three
you lost the game with white arjun's ha
gonna have the white pieces in the next
game this was an absolute Heartbreaker I
can't believe what we just saw so
without win this is crazy that was an
absolute gift and well speaking of gifts
it's holiday season so happy holidays
from chess.com right now upgrade your
chess.com account to premium membership
and get one month of Premium free you
heard that right chess.com is increasing
the seven day free trial to an entire
month for those who upgrade a premium
membership right now through the website
that's one month of unlimited game
review unlimited puzzles and a cute
little Emoji next to your username for
free don't miss this limited time offer
drop the command lto in the chat for
details and Direction we'll be right
back for more this opening matchup
between five and a carwana and our
generic I see here at the speed test
championship
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
it's it feels just like playing the
chest is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kit
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
game not in these positions within the
Tempest the best have come to test their
skills and brave the storm imagine's
down to five seconds gonna move
that was legendary stuff right there for
some this is familiar ground
fisherman four oh for others this is a
Fresh Field to prove their prowess
the moves will be fast oh my God no 97
tricked at the end the stakes will be
high
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
and we return here at the speed Chess
Championship right now Arjun aragi has a
three-point lead after the five-minute
portion against five minute caruana
Dania what in the world must Fabiana do
to mount this comeback well first of all
he's got to stop shooting himself in the
foot that last game you said it best I
think it was inexcusable he has to avoid
flagging he has to avoid making simple
blunders but overall I mean his play has
been decent I think the one specific
further change that he can make is to
play a little bit faster in critical
moments trust his Instinct he's taking
longer than Arjun in important moments
he's falling behind on the clock and
he's getting into too many time
scrambles and realistically fabi's
gotten a lot better at those Robert but
we know who the favorite is if things go
down to a Time scramble every game right
and you say he needs to trust his
instincts we need to stop trusting
Sparta chess's instincts because his
predictions were that Fabi would be the
favorite five to four in both the five
and the three plus one tie patrols that
did not come to fruition Arjuna geisi
with a six to three lead but it's not
over three point separation Arjun is a
great bullet player the prediction was
five to four uh in assuming five to five
in bullet between these two uh Bobby
does have chances this is not uh other
like a knee-haul where if they play
bullet probably probably feels like he's
got no shot with that one second
increment especially Bobby still has his
chances he's had good positions but we
have to give credit where it's due Arjun
aragassi has been a monster
he most certainly has and three points
is that threshold the car Nakamura a
couple years ago I remember his SEC
interview where he pointed out that
three points is that threshold where if
you get up to four you start talking
about a lopsided match I mean four
points just has a much different ring to
it than two points I think this first
game of the three minute portion is so
important to set the tone fabi's got to
push the last 90 minutes behind him he's
got to put through a good solid game of
the black pieces at the very least he
needs a draw here
okay well we see the start of a Tory
attack not every day you see this at the
highest level but Arjun continues to
play openings without much bite now that
may seem like an insult I actually mean
that as a compliment he is doing the
right thing in a match when he is up
three points he's just not giving a Fabi
a chance to use the opening to his
advantage
yeah and he just plays all sorts of
Sidelines this one Robert I like a lot
more than his C4 D3 garbage that we saw
in the previous game this is a little
bit more mainstream and I think this
strikes a good balance between
non-theoretical but not too passive
right and he just from Bishop F4 I was
there looking at F5 and G5 and uh
throwing the pawns for it I think that
Bobby should do that like right now I G5
was well it was before he went Knight F6
he played a little bit too fast it's
weird that I'm saying that I feel like
I'm criticizing him for playing too
slowly now I'm saying fast fast I mean
what do you want Robert yeah it's easy
to be on the sidelines I acknowledge it
most certainly is Bishop E5 on the board
but I understand what you're saying I
mean it's hard to find that happy medium
and C5 orchestrating some pressure on
the queen side as Fabiano
and I like I like Black's position again
yeah the pawn A5 don't capture it right
now because you are met by the move B2
to B4 uh but the A5 Pawn is a long-term
Target if you protect that with B4 as
white then C3 is going to be a problem
whoa what was this D4 I guess he wants
aha God he's playing like a bullet game
yeah he's looking really quickly here
and if you don't take E5 is the threat
winning H7 Pawn but I don't want to
trade all the pieces if I'm carwana yeah
and I think a instructive positional
mistake if I can show this really really
quickly H6 is on the board he's trying
to keep as many pieces on the board as
possible if you would have taken first
then then gone H6 then after Knight
takes F6 Queen takes F6 Bishop B4 this
is the kind of nightmare scenario you
want to avoid you get this type of
structure in the Catalan sometimes with
that pawn on A6 a permanent weakness the
Knight coming to E5 this is precisely
what you wanted to avoid so instead if
I'd be doing his best to keep as many
miners on the board as possible
Knight B3 I apologize for getting Bob
down there no you're fine look at the
bishop on A7 I think that Fabi needs to
play F6 at some point and now feels like
that moment there it is opening the f
file the F2 Pawn is a target C3 is also
loose so if ef6 Queen F6 uh you have to
defend C3 and stop E5 to E4 all at once
this is looking very bad terrible
you can't you can't survive this
position without a dark squared Bishop I
mean you just can't the dark squares are
too weak Black's Center play comes too
fast E5 E4 is coming I mean this is
horrible and Fabi just has to deliver
this game this is a golden opportunity
to strike yet again with the black
pieces
he simply must take advantage of this
position and he's ahead on the clock
Dunya so he's doing well in all
cylinders and rookie one good move if
you start trading on E5 the E6 Pawn
becomes a bit of a Target but Fabi just
should go for it right I think he just
trades everything plays Queen D6 at the
end kicks that Rook out of there I said
he plays Bishop B8 also love that move
yeah this is wonderful stuff
and this is so easy to play now E5 is
coming next although you shouldn't rush
E5 I mean you could play this in
different ways E5 has the drawback of
blocking out the dark squared Bishop but
if you can shove your Pawn through to E4
White's gonna start experiencing
problems with this King I mean you could
get checkmated here real easily if the
Knight jumps into E5 and then G4
so we're at three what exactly does
white do here because what you said
makes perfect sense and I'm struggling
to find an idea
like a single move you can basically
pre-move E5 and you're up a full minute
on the clock so this is looking really
bad for Archer it's interesting because
the lead is still at three but it feels
like in the last four or so games 500
actually has played the better chess
he definitely has and I think if Arjun
ends up losing this game we're going to
see some adjustments in the opening I
mean I feel like the decision to play
offbeat stuff is understandable but he's
playing a little bit too casually the
first 15 20 moves and he's getting
himself into these dubious positions but
Rook F7 wait up game over Rook F7 wins a
piece oh Rook F7 not Rook C7
yeah that might have also worked but now
you protect your Bishop on B7 F5 is lost
and at best you get a couple pawns but
you're gonna get maybe he resigns now
something is
oh I feel like with Arjun in the last
like four games
yeah I mean yeah he won the previous
game with black but he got outplayed
there as well
and this is the time for Fabi to
capitalize
and we get a more traditional opening we
were talking earlier right the bishop
left C8 the queen comes to B3 to put
pressure on the B7 Pawn it's a situation
where white has the bishop pair the H2
Pawn at some point can be captured but
it's not really important especially
with B7 uh under attack so I like the
opening Choice from Fabi but Arjun seems
prepared
I like it as well yeah this is a very
mainstream line of the slav the
structure in the center is symmetrical
but every other aspect of the position
is anything but with white holding the
bishop here I've never really liked this
type of position for black it just seems
like to quote the great Robert Hess
white controls the pawn breaks H5 E4
man what a wise guy wow
appreciate you uh give me that little
shout out there but the black king can't
castle if you're a castle kingside in
comes H5 uh B5 has just whoa whoa
is this damn girl
I I this must be yeah you were about to
both think is this prep but Fabiano's
playing instantly I mean
it has to be right Fabby doesn't play
Knight takes B5 in two seconds if it's
not prep unless no way in a heck unless
he started trusting himself all of a
sudden right where he's like oh what
would Arjun do he'd play that sacrifice
in just a couple of seconds
Rook hc1 C1
how do you defend the Knight
you don't because Queen A4 is also
piling on pressure
guess you can play the move Queen C7 to
D7 but in that position white can
actually take C6 and replace the bishop
with the queen oh my goodness is black
and moral danger already I mean queen A4
also yeah both as you said Bishop C6
followed Queen B5 or queen A4 right away
You're Just winning back your piece with
an extra pawn and even if you didn't
have an extra Pawn look at the queen
side
oh Rook C6 right
rookie C6 Knight C6 and Rook C6 that's
what I'm looking at
King f8 yeah maybe we should shouldn't
get uh
two ahead of ourselves just trade
everything on C6 right Bishop C6 take
take take and you have two outside pass
pawns yep and that's exactly what he
does
and not to mention that Rook C8 is going
to be a massive threat in the resulting
position maybe it's worth for Arjun to
try to keep the Rooks on the board but
then the bishop comes into A5
okay so First bishop d8 Rook C8 loses
the queen whoa Christopher Rook
there's some crazy ideas there with
Bishop A5 I don't think that quite works
okay what other ideas Queen A6 like a
simple move
seems okay but you're gonna lose G2 and
I'm guessing Fabi really doesn't want to
give up that pawn but that's why these
double pawns are so important don't know
remember in earlier games black was
trying to get an outside pass Pawn here
you're not getting that because your
pawns on G6 but even if Rook takes G2
comes it doesn't have devastating effect
and for that reason you can make a slow
move you mentioned Queen A6 Bishop B4
also comes to mind slicing off the only
Escape Route for white for Black's King
and Fabi makes a move kind of like that
he moves his Queen up to B5 he wants
Bishop B4 and queen C5
oh there's a mean on that Faith yeah
hello
actually Sergeant black do
take on C6 but then what because you
can't even play F6 because if Rook takes
E6 explaining the pin on the queen oh
this is over this is a demolition Rook
C6 Rook C6 keep the Queens on the board
the black king is getting made it
wow apparently the only move is Rook G1
oh come but then black and white could
even grab on Ace E6 and get a pawn up
end game that's totally winning right
rookie six Queen D7 Rook G1 and that's
done so this is over completely over
black doesn't have a move here
holy smokes look at that preparation
from Fabi
it's funny because I feel like Arjun was
avoiding that with the white pieces
right he was like playing these sort of
uh offbeat lines quiet variations and
then he with black this opening is
literally called the slav defense quiet
shallow defense right so like it didn't
stay quiet for long and Bobby just blew
him off the board
and Urgent strategy just seems reversed
I mean you're absolutely right normally
you avoid stuff with the black pieces
you play E4 G6 you play kg stuff arjun's
trying to play that kg stuff with the
white pieces it's not working out now
he's going for a main line of the black
pieces that's not working out either
Fabio looks like a new man in these last
three games excluding that very
unfortunate uh moment in uh the last
five minute game right and look at that
move rookie 65. The Rook is hanging but
you lose your Rook on C6 don't take that
Bishop C5 is a great move because the
next move is E6 for white E6 is about to
crush black when all the material so
Bishop C5 even though your queen wanted
to go there we were just talking about
it you should see if now that things
have changed a little bit is precise and
Fabi is as precise as ever
last ditch effort by Arjun to whip up
some counter play I think you could even
play Bishop takes D4 uh at an absolute
minimum and he does and E6 is still
coming
it is indeed so King f8 runs away uh you
can take on E2 but then after the queen
66 your the white King's a little
exposed so he's keeping the status quo
and now the Queen's defended on B5 means
The Rook is free to move uh this is just
Rook D6 I think he's Rook D6 but moves
like A4 those are the kinds of moves
that we take for granted from these guys
and they find them like a hundred
percent of the time
it's over goodbye wow and now it's a one
point match all of a sudden we entered
the three plus one with a three game
belief for Arjun it's down to one and I
believe chat actually predicted that
Arjun would win this time segment and
I'm sure they were biased by the fact
that he was leading the match overall
but the chat said Arjun would take this
time segment Fabiano says not so fast
yeah no and Arjun goes for another
offbeat line this time the jabova London
and H4 is actually pretty standard fair
in these types of positions you're
trying to take this sting out of Knight
H5 but you're also trying to expand on
the king side using the fact that you
have not castled yet and normally Robert
you don't want to go C5 you want to go
C6 first chase the Knight away and then
play C5 that's the way that most people
recommend playing this position Abby
goes for the immediate C5 now the
problem is how are you gonna get this
Knight off of this excellent B5 Square
yeah that's why you want to kick it to
begin with I'm with you there he just is
going to develop uh one of the big
problems though is this 905 you're not
going to capture it and so what is the
actual plan for black I I believe
there's an idea with Knight B8 here if
I'm I might be mistaken uh but just
bring the Knight towards midnight before
it's just smart he does that okay that's
way uh more active but the knights
coming to C6 was my ultimate point and
it seems to me again maybe I'm making
conclusions too quickly that Fabia
started to trust his instincts a little
bit more I mean this is the kind of move
that he might have spent a minute on 90
seconds on in the five minute portion
now obviously the time control has
reduced but he's playing a lot faster
and there's just this Pizzazz this
energy to his play in the early going
that I think bodes very well for his
chances speaking of energy G4 by Arjun
but can he sustain this I'm not sure
because Knight C3 you just take on D4
after e takes D4 uh the C2 Pawn will be
an eventual Target black doesn't have
any weaknesses and there's no actual
attack it's not like white has a bishop
on the Long die or on the B1 H7 diagonal
I should say uh going for the black king
it The Land Before stops the Bishop from
Ever Getting to D3 so I feel like uh
this is just all smoke and mirrors and
uh father should be happy about his
position as he tries to win his third
straight game in this time segment and
Arjun once again settling into a deep
think I mean Knight C3 not where you
want the Knight to be you want that c
Pawn to move to C3 that night on B4 now
resembles White's Knight on B5 and black
is the one who has a serious attack on
the queen side except you want to be
very careful about moving your queen
away and allowing G5 but this is like
the best caracon you could ever ask for
like this is this looks like those lines
in the caracon instead of the bishop
being chased to G6 it's actually safe at
home and now Knight D7 when you um have
the initiative let's trade off some
pieces H4 is under attack G5 has played
a southern F6 there is a king in the
center so once again Bobby can make this
F6 move and open the position up I mean
white is rumbling forward but he's got
zero Foundation here I mean white
literally does not have a single thing
going for him positionally and these
pawns are like the definition of a paper
tiger
and I think F6 still is good
that bunny does such a good job of
controlling H5 very important because
otherwise Bishop takes H7 would be a
sacrifice but F6 just swap on F6 if you
want and it doesn't matter the G file is
open instead goes for the queen side how
could you blame him Bobby he's a new man
right now no he totally is I mean you
could just sense it in his play now he's
not threatening Queen takes D4 obviously
oh he is
oh I just met you just made me eat my
words that's amazing let me show this on
the board
I jumped to conclusions here but yes he
is because of Knight takes C2 great
catch and you win the queen back you're
up a piece that's easy to miss it
certainly is and I was going through the
same calculation as you were and I was
like oh Queen D wait a second you didn't
stop calculating no I was just stopped
myself before Queen D4 oh he missed it
as well
look at how quickly Fabi plays it you
you could tell he that was my fault he's
a completely new player right now like
but I trusted Daniel I shouldn't have
but look at this have you ever seen
Arjun react like that I I literally
never have
no because he never blunders like this
but something is broken in his play and
you get this uh timeout this break 30
minutes through this three plus one we
saw 15 minutes to go and right now Arjun
is dropping all of his Pawns in this
game Queen 65 trades the Queen's off
there's not even an attack Fabiano
caruana is about to win his third
straight game and for full disclosure
and each Geary was messaging me about
this match oh the higher seat in trouble
well Fabiano didn't get to read that
message but right now he's saying oh
what trouble is that and I'm always so
impressed when players are able to make
these drastic adjustments mid-match and
it's just so clear that Fabi did some
self-coaching in that uh break between
the five and three minute portions he
told himself something and now he looks
like the Fabiana car one we all know and
remember bang goes the dynamite a 26
move Victory and the match is tied at
six a piece and we have another French
which part of my French I just don't
think it's a very good idea against
Fabiano caruana and with the break that
they had to study the openings to change
their uh repertoire we see a different
Dynamic right there were those Double C
pawns for Fabi in the previous French
game now he's just throwing his pawns
for developing and this is standard fair
I think a Wonder Liang played this in
the US Championship uh he had the black
side of this position against Ray Robson
and it was really interesting battle but
I do think that Fabian has a
tremendously successful history in the
French
yeah and Fabi just loves these closed
positions where there's a lot of Pawn
play a lot of maneuvering play he drops
his Knight back to H2 not mincing his
words he wants to Ram this F Pawn up the
board and I always feel Robert that
White's play uh if you're reasoning
objectively exceeds Black's play on The
Queen side I never quite understand how
black wants to make stuff actually
happen on the queen side yeah you can
play Bishop A4 Knight B3 but I feel like
White's a lot more solid and after Queen
H5 isn't quite already better
or something that's very important so F5
is what black hat in store that's what
queen H4 was played and even though the
evil bar seems to like black it's one of
these positions where if you don't make
the next three moves accurately white
has a very obvious plan Knight D2 to F3
win the H6 Pawn with Knight G4 things
like that I mean actually for right now
looks very good as well so you need to
be careful for both sides and okay Rook
G6 I like just the defensive posture of
margin I like it a lot defending H6 and
I think Knight F6 is going to be met
with Bishop to E7 and white might have
bitten off more than he can chew on the
on the king side I think the queen is
just not enough of a piece to protect
everything and manage the king side
attack but we will see I guess
technically it is a king side attack
even the White's the only king that's
sitting there well I like Bishop G4 to
H5 at some moment
um here black can go Knight B3 takes C1
and it's sort of a long-term situation
where Black's position is better you see
the evaluation bar we're not going to
argue with it but it's not clear how to
proceed even after the Knight take that
Bishop on C1 uh if you don't think the
bishop on C1 uh the White's next moves
will be Bishop F4 Rook moves Bishop G4
to H5 things like that
but the problem is that without the dark
skirt Bishop it is now virtually
impossible for white to make any
progress on his side of the board I mean
that Bishop is an integral part of
White's attack it pressures H6 it allows
white to access the weak squares on
Black's King side now I think Arjun his
hands are free they can go Bishop B3 and
Knight A4 and if the B-2 Pawn Falls then
White's position collapses like a house
of cards oh this is not looking good
right now so Arjun playing great defense
and now Bishop's ef6 Rook F6 that's two
pawns Advantage watch out for 95 you
often want to vacate that square it is a
thematic idea an F4 F5 is available for
white The Rook on F6 is kind of trapped
on you so Queen H4 if you're not paying
attention could even win that rook in
some positions this is a dicey situation
and I do like how arjun's played this
far but here is a critical moment yeah
I'm not sure you should have grabbed
that pawn he's got to react accurately
and he moves his Queen into E7
continuing to adopt that defensive
posture but Queen H4 pins The Rook okay
rookie 8 defends the queen that Rook is
still gasping for breath though
and I think F4 makes perfect sense here
and Bobby plays it played it
and F5 is a pretty substantial threat I
feel
I if I didn't know oh my God said I
would have suggested that white is
probably better here well he plays F5
and what's actually the move here
because Knight takes E5 simply D takes
E5 and your Rook is trapped oh The Rook
is fully trapped you're gonna have to
give up an exchange and allow the queen
trade
you know what I forgot about there's a
bishop on A4 I thought that D7 was just
gonna be lost but like you could
actually take on F5 because the bishop
on A4 covers that 997. it's totally
irrelevant but maybe not totally
irrelevant
it's like Ben Simmons all it really does
is defend okay you and I have been
texting about Ben Simmons he's doing a
lot better right now give the guy a
little bit of a break all right King d8
whoa that walks looking right into the
crossfire doesn't it uh this is arjun's
very scary arjun's not himself right now
no he is not I mean this king is just in
danger The Rook is still trapped night
what D5 he's gonna give up the exchange
is he gonna throw in a check on C5
no he's just gonna give up The Rook so
Bishop F5 here and just take
I'm just total collapse here for Arjun
but amazing play by fappy F4 and F5
playing patiently when he has to be
patient decisively when he has to be
decisive
can he convert this into the full point
and even that move right there King F2
that's like Ultra Precision because if
you want Rook H5 there's Rook G8 to G6
things like that so King f2's first if
Rook G8 there's Rook G1 let's trade off
those Rooks so great play even in a
winning position they often say right
the hardest positions to win are one
positions but Bobby's gonna go King E3
he's gonna go Rook G1 so King D4 he's
gonna protect everything and then just
make progress yeah I mean this is so
hard to defend in the long run you might
survive for 10 15 moves here but
eventually White's gonna find some way
to break through I think the Rooks
landing on G5 the king's moving into D4
and something's going to give here
Something's Gotta Give
uh Rook G5 looks great just protect E5
and attack H5 bring that King right into
D4 Rook D6 is available as well
no something is really wrong for Arjun
and it was the first time he was so
demonstrative and his play is super
shaky right now it I think all started
with that English game that was the game
when his playstyle started to change he
got crushed he wins the next game but
his play has not improved since then
rookie 6 obviously well actually maybe
it's not obvious that no I was gonna say
don't take on E6 but he does but B6 in
okay now can you see five
gosh this is really sloppy
and just how do you win this position I
didn't like it but now you move the Rook
away
but I didn't like Rook takes E6 to begin
with I felt like he could have just won
King D4 directly and black could have
yeah what was the point of taking and in
fact you heard what I started to say
Robert I was like obviously you don't
take on E6 here and precisely at that
moment he took the road but can you
blame me for thinking that move was
unlikely no it was unlikely and it
actually might allow a draw here Bishop
F5 to G6 like the bishop can just close
down the open files from that Rook now
wait a second maybe there's an idea of
sacking on F5 because whites white will
be a pawn down there but it'll be just a
Double H Pawn I think white should maybe
play A4 to prevent B5 and then Rook F1
but if B5 there's maybe King D4 back at
some moment that could be a zoo
that's true A4
back to D4 yeah he's no King D4 there's
gonna be a zoo
yeah he's gonna win
Kingston six Rook F1 Bishop F5 and I
think you just there's this one yeah
there's a zoo exactly
wow take that thing and then yeah this
is and then was thinking he only has 14
seconds who he leaves it wow you don't
even have to take it
Bishop Rook B2 oh oh new open file
that's huge
still Arjun holding on Bishop F5 but you
cannot take on A5
oh this is now very easy yeah
just take everything
oh
wow Fabiana car one has won four
straight games he could hardly believe
it himself and Arjun eragasi he is the
white pieces it's a Petrov okay Fabiano
caruana in his tried and true opening
his bread and butter the opening he used
uh for many years against Magnus Carlson
and others and now we see that we have a
calm position once again but what do you
think does Arden just want to make a
draw here to stop the losing streak he
needs that break he needs that halftime
break there is a break after 30 minutes
of the three minute portion he needs it
he needs a deep breath Archer never
loses four in a row he never tilts like
this and all credit of course to Fabby
who was playing amazing but look at what
fabby's doing he's playing as solid as
he possibly can that is exactly what you
want to do when you're playing a tilted
opponent because they're going to make
the mistakes you don't actually need to
do all that much if you're in Fabby
shoes right now
and the best thing that top players do
is even when it looks like a draw we see
Magnus Carlson do this for so many years
they still keep a little something there
to play for more and I think Knight D5
here for Fabiano there's a knight
landing on F4 next move this is starting
to look really good the way he's
positioned his Bishops is so impressive
instead he plays a Tamer move he plays
H6 no Knight D5 looked was begging to be
played
I think he's happy with the score right
now and he's like I have the black
pieces let's just take it easy make a
drug it comes to the classical approach
but I think he missed a chance there but
actually I think white still might be a
little bit worse that Bishop on H2 is
totally out of commission normally in
the Petra if the pawn is on D5 here it's
on D6 okay now it's already five oh I
hated that move
Bishop
I did not like the trade and opening
that that seemed completely unnecessary
Here and Now Queen G3 I guess the A4
Pawn is also hanging
so it's interested by C6 and then go
rookie eight and
um he wants C5
not C6
and queen A4 you can't take on D5 as
Queen D1 check
but maybe after Queen a for this bishop
G7 and then maybe an Intermezzo check on
D1
just wants to draw here
is he getting it that's the big question
so
don't take any two because A6 is hanging
and then you go down a pawn
he missed he might have he he missed it
but he still is King G7 because rookie
ate Queen at Queen takes D5 there's
Queen E1 check takes F2 so he has
everything under control
yep and that's precisely what's going to
happen but G5 is hanging as well so
maybe I was wrong about the control as
is B2 as is C7 so White's going to
emerge upon up
right oh this is a big messed up I mean
if Fabi had gone Knight D5 there I don't
think he would have lost the game now
he's suddenly on the cusp of losing that
past d-pawn is just gonna Rumble up the
board can black Garner some sort of
Perpetual check maybe a G4 at a timely
moment I don't know and this is exactly
what Arjun needed because even if he
doesn't win this game he feels like he
can be the stronger player he can have
the advantage so Fabiano makes mistakes
he just showed you that in this game so
for Arjun you need to not even win this
game but just find your belief in
yourself yeah you need to stop the
bleeding because a five game winning
streak is just going to enter crazy
territory that's a mick adoption Queen
takes C7 it's safe to say Arjun is not
going to lose this game but can he drive
that deep on home so the problem is if
your Pongo is a D6 that covers the
diagonal your queen is very importantly
covering the F4 square and all these
checks so D5 D6 looks very nice but d5s
have a queen D2 and then D6 there's
Queen F4 check with the immediate draw
and one way you can lose the game is
after D5 Queen D2 if you drop your queen
back to E5 you have to reckon with the
queen trade on F4 and Black's King is
better placed so maybe white can
establish the protected passer there but
that needs to be calculated very
carefully
for sure and this looks like
um it's one of these situations done if
this were a classical game and then you
make a draw you're kind of like I had
some chances just to put more pressure
on my opponent but for Arjun I think the
key thing here is he's never worse in
this game I mean there there was that
moment with Knight D5 that we talked
about it was just kind of a flash in the
pan uh but here he has everything under
control so at least that will feel good
for him as they head to the halfway
break yeah he just needs a little bit
more confidence a feeling that he can
dictate the course of the game as you're
saying and I think the accurate move
here for Fabi is Queen to D4 you have to
prevent White's Queen from dropping back
to E5 and he is not about to give Arjun
another opportunity at this game great
move and white would love to play the
move A5 here and after B takes A5 C5 and
he goes for A5 but the D5 Pawn is loose
so I think he's what's the idea after ba
yeah scary as it looks to allow
connected passers it's not all that
dangerous and wait a second king E8 and
fc5 queen F4 wins for black oh my
goodness the pawns promote
but he can just take an A6 and allow the
enemy to draw I think you have to do
that
[Laughter]
just just go Queen takes A6 Queen F4
Queen C1 you know they make a drawn that
way but do not blunder queen of Fortune
and do not just try to play some random
move to keep the game going you cannot
afford to lose another game right now
and you've got to take the wise route as
unpleasant as it is to give up another
white game you called it stabilize make
the draw go to the break you're only
down in Point if you're Arjun
right and he was getting blanked in this
time control so even the draw will be
important for his confidence and for
Fabiano what a comeback it's been down
three points losing he lost on time he
lost some time in the final five minute
game and yet he came out blazing hot in
this time I can't believe it was down
three points 30 minutes ago
wow yeah it feels like forever at this
point don't take F7
no no no
don't even think about it okay it's a
Perpetual check
and there it is
okay
and cool finally break time for these
players so they are gonna leave
work on some of their openings just get
some fresh legs and fresh eyes uh but
now I can't believe we're saying this
down here it is a one point lead for
Fabiano caruana as our generation leaves
his room and gets Refreshments I mean
it's just been two completely different
matches a match one ended with about 15
minutes left in the five minute portion
and then match two began and Fabi is the
best race to use a new man he's
confident he's trusting his Instinct
he's getting better positions with both
colors Arjun needs a 180. I think he
needs to play more principled fashion
with white and maybe play more casually
with black rather than with white as I
said earlier I'm excited to see what
changes Arjun is going to bring to the
table in the second half of the three
minute portion well we will find out
after this short break here at the speed
Chess Championship brought to you by
chess.com but for now just take a step
back and relax and continue to join the
show when returned in just a few
thank you
[Music]
International Master Danny wrench back
again Chief chess officer bringing you
chess terminology let's Dive Right into
one of one of everybody's favorite
tactics if I might be so bold because
it's surprising it's something that
never never fails to deliver shock value
and excitement whether you're watching a
broadcast or just reviewing some famous
chess games and that is the process of
an under promotion when you move upon to
the other side of the board almost
always you're looking to get a queen but
the rare times where it's better to get
something else or perhaps even required
in order to maybe not stalemate your
opponent or keep your winning chances
alive are some of the most fascinating
exciting moments in chess so with that
let's dive into what under promotion is
and show you some of my favorite
examples under promotion as we said is
the process of promoting a pawn but not
to the most obvious or most powerful
type of piece which is usually the queen
in this famous example between Nakamura
and Vladimir kramnik the fact that
Hikaru was winning is only because he
under promotes on C8 to a knight that
move comes with check on the black king
so that on the next turn white can
capture the E2 pawn it should be noted
that if Hikaru had queened
black would actually go on to win
because now black queens with check and
ultimately chromic would have been able
to not just save but actually win this
game another promotion tactic provided
to me by our own Sam Copeland vice
president of content one of his favorite
examples is the move D7 and after Bishop
to E8 the only way to win the game is to
underpromote to a bishop under voting to
a bishop doesn't happen that often in
this particular study it was designed to
be so the point is that if the bishop
moves over to H5 we check and mate along
the A4 E8 diagonal and if the bishop
moves anywhere else white actually plays
a subtle move Bishop of seven first and
there is no way to prevent checkpoint on
the next move shout out to everybody
watching this video thank you for tuning
in and enjoying our breakdown of under
promotion and we'll see you on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
and we are back here at the speed Chess
Championship it is the matchup between
Fogo and carwana and Arjun eragasti we
are halfway through it is a close one
and Donya it's been a really fun match
thus far and there's a lot of prize
money at stake between these two players
there most certainly is you can see the
Distribution on the table in front of
you I mean these are mouth-watering
totals for a grand total of 100 G's
that's the total prize full as if the
players need any more motivation to go
after each other
they certainly do not in these Blitz and
bullet time controls they just have a
good time with it and we are about to
get back into the three plus one time
Patrol and Don is something that I
mentioned earlier that sometimes in this
format players are not used to five plus
one so they take a little bit too much
time here then they uh take go too
quickly at other points I feel like Fabi
has found his form in the three plus one
and he won a title Tuesday recently in
this exact time control it's something
he's more accustomed to and maybe that's
just what he needed it's like a bolt and
he is right back in this match and in
fact has the lead he has the lead he has
the white pieces and let's see what
adjustments Arjun has made in these last
four minutes the very tame system by
Fabi getting the bishop out to D2 and he
might be Castle in Queen side I am
actually familiar no he goes Rook D1
almost almost Queen side Castle but
instead he plays very positionally here
I believe you it reminded me of like a
Cambridge Springs except the Bishops on
DJ rather than out on G5 but either way
it's a solid setup start to this game
and for Arjun do you play B6 Bishop B7
and C5
I think so more like an Oxford Winters
um
it's my first one of the day you know so
I've held out for over an hour that
really hurt me just for the record that
one hurt my soul good
uh you know this is interesting because
the Evo Bar says better for black Donya
but I think we both agree that the move
C6 to C5 is what the this entire
position is about
yeah I mean it really it is only a
question of when you play the move white
could try to restrict it with b2b4 but
even that doesn't fully prevent C5
instead Arjun he starts by building up
his King side play establishing the 984
the last thing you want to do
if you're Fabiano is Play Bishop takes
E4 that is just verboten in these types
of positions not happening certainly not
with fe4 happening and uh just opening
the position for Black's pieces so Queen
A4 I feel like A5 is automatic and I was
going to suggest Rook takes C6 until I
realized the Rooks on D1 on C1 and Fabby
poking and prodding Bishop takes a five
is sort of a threat I think it actually
is a threat
what a weird threat I know but the queen
doesn't get trapped there it can escape
via C6 or even A6
I was looking at the diagonal of A2 to
G8 and you're like Bishop takes a5's a
thread he goes Rook 8 so he sees it
takes it just like you it takes it very
seriously actually I mean he dedicates
an entire Rook to stopping the threat
no I like Black's position I mean the
Knight on e4 is the most advanced piece
on the board but what is the break where
is Black going from here C5 has always
giving up the B5 squared making D5 lose
he plays G6 I like the patience from
Arjun I'm still just waiting for that
next plan
and Fabby is also waiting for that next
plan I don't think Fabi is seriously
considering the move B3 I think he's
just sort of uh playing that uh you know
posturing game where he's setting
himself up in case the position opens up
arjun's still making improving moves
Knight df6 of course the drawback is
that you yield the E5 square but if
white puts that on 95 prematurely then
black can take on C3 take on E5 and he
does play B3 are you as surprised as I
am you were just calling it and he plays
no way I'm not sure I like it because
with B5 at the end of the sequence as
you were indicating the bishop on B7
looks bad but as you've said many times
a bad Bishop defends good pawns and the
A3 Pawn is a terrible one and now it's
gone that pawn is not long for this
board he has just eliminated it and you
cannot take on B6 here that drops the
bishop on C3 Fabius just flat out down
upon here and I don't think he's got too
much to show for it yeah it looks like
he just blundered if we're being honest
and good play uh thus far by Arjun a
really nice second half to begin uh this
time Patrol I mean he needs to feel the
momentum he needs to believe in himself
and right now he's out playing Fabiano
caruana and that last game was actually
a very important one that stable draw
that he made from a position of strength
I think you called it it wasn't a result
that would satisfy him in the moment but
it convinced him that no he's not gonna
lose every game in the three minute
portion yes he can still call the shots
against Fabi and that's exactly what
he's doing in this game but can he
capitalize on this opportunity he's up
upon Bishop takes E4 has been played and
Fabi does have certain Assets in this
position Robert I mean Black's King
isn't feeling too comfortable the queen
side pawns are still weak so one mistake
could turn this around immediately right
I mean look at the King on G8 the bishop
on A1 at some point dc5 is in the air
but Queen C7 a nice move saying no D
take C5 for you the E5 Knight needs the
defense and Rook B1 Rook A8 looks like
the choice for Arjun go to the open file
attack the bishop 101. yep and Rook A8
indirectly defending the B6 Pawn in the
event of Queen takes B6 takes take Rook
takes A1 is a check and 92 by Fabi
dragging his Knight over potentially
that form maybe also to C3 and B5 I
really like the way fabi's handling this
very difficult situation and C4
committal Choice from Arjun what he
wants to do is protect B6 which is
defend tactically but he would love to
play B5 to B4 that's easier said than
done but if he's able to accomplish that
he's immediately winning he is indeed
and of course Fabi he holds Arjun in the
highest possible regard I mean these
players respect each other
we remind you that in his podcast
episode recently Fabi picked Eric icy as
perhaps the most talented Junior saying
that his chess is incredible and Arjun
has shown that here I mean out playing
Fabi like he's managed to do thus far
has been nothing short of amazing but
that four-point comeback by Fabiana
Carona has turned this match on its head
and yet a big opportunity here for Our
Generation to strike back and tie the
match Bishop C6 is on the board Arjun
trying to shove that pawn down B4 and I
think fabi's running out of resources
here Robert yeah he looks like he's
getting away with it B5 B4 looks
borderline Unstoppable Arjun down to 40
seconds that's the one thing I have as a
concern and Bishop E8 that looks like
The Prudent choice because you need the
queen defending Bishop B4 I don't know
about that that gives up a lot of the
dark squares that's gonna make it really
hard for black to shove that pawn down
to B4
and it's a good illustration the bishop
pair is strong but having just a lone
Bishop not always great so Rook takes
before was available and said it was
Queen E1 Now The Bishop's hanging so it
goes back to D6 yeah a little shaky for
margin right here and what I would I
would not repeat with Fabia that's
exactly what I was gonna say 92
excellent positional move he's going to
move his Bishop back up to C3 and create
that massive blockade on the dark
squares he's gonna say hey Arjun you're
up a pawn that's great how are you ever
gonna get this Pawn at B4 and here come
the knights then I can go to E6 into C5
for example because if you ever uh take
the Knight on C5 you open up the long
diagonal so H3 comp play from Fabi Queen
E7 Arjun still trying to prepare before
doing what he can and Rook B8 probably
next how is probably going to stop that
Rook A4 is also a big threat I think oh
even better oh I think Rook A4 just wins
you should pay five might have been the
only chance there
uh just a Stop The Rook from getting to
A4 good point yep
now everything is in place before it's
happening on the next move
Valiant defense by Fabi but I think it's
coming to an end Rook A4 Bishop A4 the
B4 square is still defended
well Queen A2 okay he wants queen a
check if the bishop moves the problem is
that the Queen's gonna block that check
he just goes Queen E8 can you play no
but yes yes no Bishop B4 was good the
best try I think oh and then Knight
takes C4 wow exactly now it's the
opportunity train has sailed the show
Here Comes
oh C3 you can just keep pushing the
pawns C2 still trying Bishop D2 he's
still gonna blockade those squares
oh an a force hanging out oh that dive
is open that's a bit scary he stops B2
and Bishop two seconds for Arjun Bishop
B2 now just bring the bishop back
covering oh my God
Bishop h8 is on Deck Queen A3 is
available as well yup infiltrating
stopping C1 oh my gosh we need to be
doing this
Queen takes B3 you can take that pawn
and then take on D5 with check oh he
misses H5
no his King's Way Too open now so Arjun
he's fighting tooth now he gets that we
need to Queen E2 is over
Queen F3 King G5 still trying
where's the mate
where is the mate he's got four seconds
to find it
oh E4 is a good try
three seconds King H6 maybe just run
away Queen takes G4 but that might be a
draw oh my gosh oh my God
King H7
the pawn I don't see the mate I don't
see the mate
I don't either this is unbelievable King
G5 back he's got no time Bishop FC I
mean why black could lose this if you
allow a check on a stop it's a drop and
neither player can boom look at Arjun he
didn't know it was a three-time
repetition and he is mad and that is the
second time in the match we've seen
Arjun react and he is in disbelief
because he had that game in the bag
that is probably the most ridiculous
comeback of this match and we've had
quite a few at this point
I we kind of thought the game was over
right those pawns were I mean it was it
looked completely devastating and then
he opened up the long diagonal when he
took that Knight on C5 down here that
gave Bobby the chances he needed to go
after the black king and that honestly
was the big mistake he did have mate
later on in the game but at that point
you can't really blame him for missing a
computer move with three seconds left
right
no the mistake was allowing the activity
exactly like once the diagonals opened
up you already felt like he was losing
the threat he missed some kind of
Checkmate or uh some win there but it
was with two seconds on his clock so
right now we're in this game here no no
this H4 ideas they work in some
positions there are some ideas with
Knight takes F6 Bishop H7 Knight G5
going for the attack uh but if it
doesn't lead to some sort of big threat
then you may start regretting putting
your Pawn out there yeah I mean it
really commits the king to a a solitary
life in the center
I'm thinking are you thinking what I'm
thinking I certainly am Knight F6
guess who's not thinking that
Arjun let me bring up an analysis board
oh yeah for sure pretty sure that was
what was available to him bang bang and
a souped up Greek gift sacrifice that
pawn on H4 is so important because after
Knight G5 taking its Unthinkable opening
up the H file and in every other way
this functions as a classic Greek gifter
the Eva bar is it even so maybe there's
some draw there and perhaps Arjun knows
the line well enough and Fabi calculated
it so I was reacting because I really
thought it was there but the players
they are not so bothered Apparently
after Queen H5 the simple Bishop A6 of
course who wouldn't see this move
allowing Queen takes up and check and
allowing a Perpetual apparently that
Bishop on F6 guards G7 so why doesn't
have anything more than a Perpetual but
anyways was Bishop A6 the only move in
that position
I think it might be
let's check that yes it is that is
absurd that is ridiculous well because
white threatens Queen takes off stamina
just Queen takes B7 yeah but there's so
many different moves right that just
seem reasonably Queen D7 and stuff like
that but it's Bishop D6 I know and
you're able to say that but it just so
oh
and then Queen E8 I'm sorry to cut you
off Robert no I'm done no I'm I'm glad
you did because get out of here it's too
absurd the game that we're seeing right
now is also absurd because they're
broken off the rails you know a rook
lift that's not going anywhere you need
95 Rook G3 things like that uh or H5 92
or Knight G6 so I feel like Arjun
has chances here he needs to capitalize
he needs to make the most of them it's
like when I visited this haunted house
called the Winchester House in San Jose
California you would walk into an
elevator or a door and it would lead
absolutely nowhere you'd just be staring
at a closed shaft that's like that Rook
on H3
highly recommended by the way if you're
a fan of
haunted places and you find yourself in
the Bay Area anyways A3 no I White's
position Robert is on the cusp of
falling apart if Fabby can find a chance
to squeeze through E5 there will be hell
to pay on the third rank
for sure and queen C2 lining up against
the F5 pump maybe there's D5 to be on
the lookout for so maybe black should
play D5 like just take it out of White's
hands but said Knight E7 opening the
bishop on B7
yep Bishop on B7 is open Bishop takes F3
has to be considered but for White's
perspective maybe it's time to
preemptively strike with D5 and he does
so what's going on after e takes D5
Knight F5 Knight F5 Bishop F5 starting
to look complicated with the tension the
position but there might also be a
knight E4 move right here as and there
was Bishop G6 that cuts off the queen
and the bishop battery
I have no idea who even has the
initiative here don't even ask me for an
evaluation
can they both have the initiative it's
just I think they both do
both players with Knight D4 protecting
the bishop uh Rook F3 at some point is
going to be quite annoying to deal with
gosh this is hard to calculate re
D takes C4 Pawn captured Rook F3 played
Bishop H7 threatened that's all I can
tell you all I can tell you is that
there's a throw you is that there's a
threat Queen H5 here yeah I'm stopping
your threat while attacking your Pawn on
H4
yeah 57 seconds for Fabi I mean
I could see myself thinking for 30
minutes in this position no I have no
idea what to do after Queen H5 so it
plays it
is Queen takes H4 it is a threat because
you have Queen H1 but your Rook at four
move just attacks E4 and forces D5 but
D5 is a useful looking move anyway
yeah but kg1 he's taking the sting out
of the move Queen takes H4 I think now
he wants black to play Queen's H4 then
Rook F4 Forks the queen in the night no
I think White's better D5 right now okay
it's King h8 running to the corner
okay
this position give me a headache if I'm
being honest so tricky yeah where's the
Advil I mean this is great maybe rookie
won but that walks The Rook right into
the crosshairs of the black Rook
Bishop Bishop D7
our reaction is always the same we just
save the move in like the surprise tone
I was I was looking at six different
moves and Bishop D7 wasn't one of them
Rook E5 do you remember Fabi played a
rookie five earlier in the match when he
had that attack he ended up losing that
game uh but it was a useful move
regardless yeah I totally remember that
it was like the queen D6 Queen G3 game
where he had the attack and
Arjun took on A5 anyway neither here nor
their card I'm yeah no it's
I just turned 27. exchange Sacrifice
from black there uh right now it's a
Knight and a pawn for Rook but that
fisherman f8 is about to go to sacking
it back I was gonna say that seemed
tempting
so Rook D7 is about to hurt it's right
you can't really prevent it I mean you
can't play Bishop C6 and he does don't
take on C4 that Rook on d1's gonna be
hanging easy to miss
um and H4 is hanging as well
you also don't want to go G4 that
reopens the bishop and allows Queen
takes H4 yeah that's off the table as is
G3 because the queen of three 18 seconds
for Arjun he's down the clock just like
Fabi he needs to find a move here what's
crazy is how Black's Bishops are
controlling all of the key squares on
the D file and now they're attacking as
well yeah H4 is hanging for real oh my
gosh
Bishop E3 trying to douse the Flames of
the initiative with the trade Bishop E4
Bishop E4 the queen is cannot take it oh
that was a great move instead he hits
the bishop but the bishop drops back and
takes the pawn in comes the queen oh G2
is three in Comes The Rook
G7 he's just saying I'm one check not a
big deal running away
Rook h8 attacking H4 there's a check on
D7 the king is driven out into the world
goodbye Queen sucks
[Music]
Oh Donna you spoke too quickly for your
own good there I apologize
oh my goodness sorry what Square was
that just for the record
that's a one commentator lost his job
don't don't you dig me further into this
hole I'm already turned it even all
oh God I just want to know where that
Queen was going to so uh
oh my goodness what a game what a
ridiculous you believe that was one game
like that entire thing was just one game
yeah and we have an even match which I
also can't believe considering the back
and forth nature of this one
sorry
anywho we are in deep breaths iqp
position this Pawn on D4 does not have a
friend in a file next to it D5 is
something that white wants to get in I
feel like this is a terrible Choice yeah
Fabby just Waltzing himself into just a
bad position with white
yeah I always hate having the isolated
Queen Pawn I feel much more comfortable
playing against it and you just control
the D5 square like right now Knight D5
starts trading everything but Fabi does
have great experience in these
structures so he knows what he's doing
and of course you can consider how
active white spaces are in the center
that cannot be sneezed at in Bishop D3
Queen G3 White's got all sorts of
attacking ideas but as long as black
maintains the blockade on the D5 square
with every piece that's traded the
luster of White's initiative gets
diminished further and further and the
significance of Black's long-term
advantages increases
for sure I mean look at what arjun's
doing he's just planting his Knight on
C4 let's trade and if you trade all of
the miners in C4 then if Queen D5 will
eventually happen so look at this bishop
takes C4 typically you see people trade
night for night but Fabiano understands
the Dynamics here he needs to keep some
activity and Knight E5 is a
well-positioned piece the bishop on the
light squares was doing nothing and they
can also be used kind of as a chisel you
can drop it back to G4 and replace the
Knight with a bishop there's
obviously made threats Galore and black
and push the pawn up to F6 at the right
moment I wouldn't do it immediately but
it can be done if you're desperate to
cover the dark squares for sure and look
at this a Trader Bishops is offered here
um will Fabiano Retreat his Bishop I
don't think so because Bishop G3 there
was C3 for black so he goes Queen G4 say
let's trade on my terms get my queen
active and watch out for Queen H6 at
some point H4 H5 things of that nature
9g4 Knight F6 and C3 comes to mind to
open up the queen side I'm not sure
entirely who that favors I would imagine
that it favors black with that monster
Bishop sitting on D5 but Arjun probably
investing some time making sure that he
doesn't get mated on the king side
so it plays Rook BH just going after the
Beats upon first and something to note
is the queen on d8 is stuck defending
the D7 Square for a while because Knight
D7 would be a fork easy to forget about
that
Rook to D2 defending B2 maybe the black
girl can sneak into B3
not sure what that does exactly just a
cool looking move
oh he plays it
I think that H4 is what I would look at
he goes Rook E3 instead just trading off
the active black Rook
Queen B6 so easy to blunder Knight D7 in
these types of positions it's I mean
it's easy to remember it at one point
and then forget about it when The Rook
moves away from B8
for sure uh so watch out for 97 ideas
and what else can you do you don't want
to really take on E3 I feel like so he
goes Queen B8 so the Knight is pinned
Knight is Bend and if white plays okay
also beats two is hanging
so we have a trade
I feel like strategically Black's in
huge trouble right now
really right because because of the the
dark squares on the king side exactly
like right now I the bishop on D5 looks
good but even if the Queens got traded
that Knight could get to C5 at some
moment so I'm worried about the dark
squares left and right but then I'm
realizing the pawn on B3 is so good that
Rook C8 to C2 is available for black at
some moment as well so I think it's uh
the pawn is a huge long-term asset and
you're right as long as the Queens stay
on the board white should have good King
side chances if the Queens are off the
board then the battle transitions over
to the queen side and blacks assets
become more obvious the bishop becomes a
lot stronger in the end game right so
Queen H6 does keep the queens of the
board the threat for black now is F6 to
trade those Queens after the Knight has
to retreat so Queen H6 he goes to Queen
E3 he Retreats first but here Rook C8
looks very good to me threading a back
ring Checkmate eventually trying to play
Rook C2
um hmm ooh that's not a good sign no we
treat it at all backing it up
backing it up and now you don't have
access to that G4 Square anymore black
can finally breathe peacefully on the
king side
there Comes The Rook
what's the actual threat for black how
do you continue here if you've got a few
free moves
how would I continue with the black hole
probably I'd put a queen on the C file
and then I'd sort of make a blank
expression and throw my hands up I think
I think Quincy seven to C4 is where it's
at because then you threaten to trade on
D2 and win the D4 Pawn so I I think
Queen C7 is a good start and King F2 is
unavailable because H2 would be angry
yeah Queen C4 let's party and F3 creates
Luft but it also creates obviously
weaknesses on the on the king side
Rook C1 and queen F1 could follow if the
Knight moves away from D3 and Arjun
playing a more patient move but I really
liked your idea I thought Queen C7
should have been the first order of
business for black you like my idea
because it was your idea you told me
Queen on the C file so I said hey sounds
good I like your idea because it was my
idea but it was ultimately your idea
that it was my idea
and Rook F2 played one thing to watch
out for is if whatever takes on C2 and
the King can get over there it could be
a losing end game for black so black has
the initiative black has good control
but if you just forget that Rook takes
C2 is available then it can be an issue
so Knight E1 let's trade on my terms it
says Fabi please take me on F2 the king
will take back
and a hard decision to make I like the
idea of keeping the Rooks on the board
also because of the clock situation it's
just so hard to contain Black's Queen
side play with 30 seconds on the clock
but fabby's doing a good job of it he
moves his Knight back to D3 obviously he
doesn't mind a repetition there's no way
arjun's repeating here no maybe six
maybe but Knight C5 on this and then oh
E5 Queen 65 The Rook yeah remember the
check we both were looking at the same
square yep
and be careful of your origin because
now without much time the king safety
not clear in the dark squares so 20
seconds for Arjun God gotta go Fabby can
just find an opportunity to make some
left I would just throw that H Pawn up
to give yourself a square he goes H3 I
was looking at H4 but he's playing a
little bit more cautiously
and now what yeah you don't want to go
F4 and reopen the bishop no I would hate
that
he's losing D4 though
Rook D4 and 1966 Rook do you want check
oh and it's happening oh this is a
really bad instrumental
and you can see on his face Queen E5 oh
and Rook D1 it's over he blundered that
Knight
God everything's what are those pieces
Fabi in time trouble it uh rears its
ugly head and Arjun Eric geisey talk
about a comeback he was up three points
he lose four games in a row and now he
has regained the lead so great showing
here great rebound by Arjun honestly
just taking a moment to appreciate this
match has been amazing this is our first
SCC match and it bodes really well for
this season it's a one-point match we've
got six minutes to play in the three
minute portion there's 30 minutes of
bullet coming up and Fabi has to improve
his performance in these time scrambles
he really does I mean he just won the
seconds are dwindling that's when he
struggles the most and look at this once
again Arjun play H4 H5 throwing up the
pawn it's been working out for him so
why not
and is doing it across several different
openings yeah it's easy to forget that
it's not just uh jabala London or things
like that it's every single time he's at
White in the last bunch of games that
Pawn's going forward and notice that the
last time they had this position Fabby
managed to squeeze his Knight into B4
this might not seem significant this
time he goes back the other way through
B8 always have to be very careful about
Knight C7 but the point is that after
Knight takes 87 Knight takes D7 The Rook
would have an Avenue of Escape reopened
he
wants that Knight to go back to A3
that's not a very good Square
so now for Fabi does he
take on D4 these little decisions are
very difficult when to release the
tension when to keep it there he just
plays Knight C6 instead and uh the evil
bar doesn't seem to like it and it's
similarly difficult decision from
White's perspective Bishop takes E4 is
tempting in such positions especially
because it carves out the C4 Square for
that A3 Knight you could take C4 a take
E4 take D7 and then plant the Knight on
C4 you're threatening a fork on B6 that
might be a sort of easily pre-packaged
small Advantage for Arjun I think he's
probably seriously contemplating it at
this very moment
uh he plays Bishop takes it before and
look at Fabi he pre-moved D takes E4 uh
he wasn't calcium Knight takes E5 into
mezzo things like that he is trusting
himself will that of an end game it's
still a pretty good Pawn but now its job
is to clamp down on Black's potential
Pawn majority on the king side and it's
a crippled upon majority because black
now has these doubled Evans Fabi not
rushing to recapture the C5 Pawn what do
you make of that B4 would be the
potential drawback of playing a move
like this but I don't think that white
can get away with it uh I think you're
yeah you're asking for trouble by
keeping your Pawn so I do not believe
that arjun's gonna play the move before
but if he does play B4 I think Rook D3
comes to mind Bishop F6 and C3 is in
trouble yeah I mean I think white needs
a couple more moves for B4 to become a
serious possibility maybe just one more
move Rook HD1 so this might be an
opportune moment to snap that pawn off
on C5 Abby's also probably considering
throwing in Rook 88 Rook HD1 hard to say
who benefits in the event of a four Rook
trade maybe neither side I mean maybe it
just
I don't know E5 okay that's what he was
thinking about but I think the closer we
get to a King and pawn and game the
better whites winning chances are so I
think trading all the Rooks should be
good for white because you essentially
have an extra Pawn oh
what's up I just don't like the look of
Knight C4 B4 and B5
okay so he goes Knight C4 step one and
in your
uh how do you stop this actually yeah no
let me just show why this is so
dangerous after B4 you have to stay on
this diagonal which means your only move
is Bishop A7 but now B5 comes with great
effect and if you take goodbye I mean
it's curtains after B6 that's how fast
this happens
sorry to cut you off there I just no
it's a good one how dangerous this was
so fabulent Rook E8 and after B4 I'll
have to move his Bishop back on the to
f8 so now Knight B6 doesn't come with a
fork that's the big uh thing here that's
why the Rook left A8 but still B5 looks
good if you can open up the a file your
Rook on A1 develops where it sits and
origin does not need to be asked twice
he has taken command of this match yeah
I mean he's just ripping Fabby apart in
this end game Rook H to D1 could come at
a very inopportune moment for black as
well resting control of the D file the
E5 Pawn is hanging he grabs it and this
is just going down the toilet for Fabby
in this game
okay so Rook D5
isn't Rook takes E5 and a6b5 dual
threats
they are indeed
so why is the eval bar so happy with
White's position
hmm there must be a move here of some
sort maybe B6 no the Knight C8
I feel like this needs to be made for
giving up the night
probably and that's what Audrey might
need to do but this is one of those
cases where having the evil bar is like
okay A Move Like C4 and giving up the
Knight and just using the extra Pawn on
the queen side but when we learn about
Chess two minor pieces are better than a
rook so it's very difficult to give up
rook takes E5
and he does
but he does it in a very interesting way
he gives Fabian out
apparently the move was C4 that would
have forced the kind of an end game
origin wanted I think you might have
missed Rook takes D1 he did he forgot
that the Rook did not have to take the
Knight and now it's even material and
that means that not that it's a draw not
definitively but some of the worst is
behind uh Fabi and he's ahead on the
clock he is but he's taking his time
there dropping his Bishop out to D6
forcing the trade of Bishops ruining
White's King Side Pawn structure black
is making major improvements to his
position here B4 F 94 F5 yes
this could be a double-edged ending now
he plays F5 immediately
and what's he doing because FG 94 Arjun
definitely playing for win look at what
he's doing he's trying to force Fabian
to calculating and he's doing a good job
of it Fabby down to 30 seconds again
this is where he has struggled immensely
in this match can he pull himself
together in the time scramble phase Rook
C4 though ba and Brooks this was a great
decision by Fabiano now Knight B5 is a
big threat Pawn to B5 looks good as well
and now its origin is down the clock and
the point of Rook B1 was to prevent the
knight from jumping to B5
95. great move 97 is the last game of
three minute time control Knight D5
check and you win before you win before
but white might be able to win B5 if the
king's sidesteps the checks adroitly no
he takes F5 okay I don't know about that
Knight c37 by Knight D6 and black has
this outside pass Pawn all right careful
now
King F6
and King Jing G5 or do you go Knight D5
so many decisions to make so little time
to make them he makes 95 he wants to be
four Pawn he's worried and he made the
right decision losing the game
Knight takes before
now it's largely a two result game black
should not be risking here at all
so where is he goes Knight C6 and Knight
takes a 495 check you get the G4
opponent or qg5 and if you can and if
you can also win H5 then you have
winning chances don't play 95 because 94
check that would be oh so easy to
blunder he goes back to E7 King G5 now I
think black's winning gotta try it King
G4 this is
it's a two-on-one and White's King is
really far away King takes H5 no there's
a problem for Arjun but it's a problem
for Fabi the king gets into D6 H5 H4 oh
he's gonna give his Knight up for the
epon at the right moment right you have
to wait until it gets towards E7 but H4
exactly exactly what he's doing Knight
defense and he's still not over don't
play King of three I don't think play H2
first I think Knight E5 we're gonna have
simultaneous promotion but Black's gonna
be up at night right
six check wins on the spot oh great cash
by you it's a winning Pawn end game oh
my goodness are we about to head to the
bullet with a tide match amazing it's
nine nine what a win by fappy these two
when it looks like one of them is about
to pull away the other Strikes Back
right Fabiano down three points in the
five plus one he wins four in a row
Arjun looking shaky he wins a couple in
a row and just when it looks like Arjun
has a good end game remember Donna he
was better he had the better Pawn
structure it looked like he was gonna
play for win Fabi is able to take home
this game send us the bullet with a tie
that the significance of this game
cannot be overstated if Fabby ends up
winning this match this might be the
game where he did it I mean Arjun was
playing without risk he was foaming at
the mouth how did he played that move C4
instead of Rook D1 we might be singing a
very different tune instead we are
singing this two in the matches tied
seat belts are fastened speed belts I
guess I'm supposed to say we've got 30
minutes of scintillating bullet action
coming very soon and just like Ben
Simmons has done with your criticism
Bobby he's done with everyone
criticizing his Mouse speed that was
really good stuff from him even keep it
up in the bullet but Arjun Air Guys
nine to nine here at the speeches
Championship brought to you by chess.com
we back for the bullet portion in just a
few
[Music]
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess
chess quack quack
play duck chest the duck is a brick
pieces cannot move through the square
occupied by the duck okay kind of
squared to place the dog
[Music]
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the pawns King to win oh wow oh there's
no stalemate but still wait there is
still meat but the still made the player
wins ooh if only that was real chess I
think I'm getting the hang of this game
I think I'm I think I actually am
getting the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dark chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the fast time winning
duck chests that
I won
yeah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
in return here at the speed Chess
Championship 2022 this is our bracket
we're starting in the top right hand
side of things five minute carwana our
generic guys he knotted up nine points a
piece but Dania all around this bracket
there are absolute Killers across the
board most of these players do have a
shot and knocking off even the best
players like Hikaru and Magnus and I
always say this at the start of
tournaments I think that's what really
lends a tournament a magical quality
it's the fact that you could virtually
make a case for every player obviously
there are favorites there are two of
them to be exact Hikaru and Magnus but
people like Dimitri on draken levonne
aronian Alexander grishock the Quantico
qualifier I mean the players playing
today for goodness sakes they can make a
Deep Run and they can knock off one of
the favorites but right now we have a
tide match with 30 minutes of bullet to
go can we ask for anything more epic
than this to kick off the C the cgc the
SEC
no this is going to be an excuse look at
the ratings by the way Fabiano 30 45 in
very important bullet chess did not
expect that and playing B3 is Hikaru
playing this match now but already a
mistake I think Knight F3 you're not
supposed to play kind of a souped-up
reverse alakine type of structure going
higher
I think that Bobby's gonna do what Bobby
wants to do he says I don't care what
you say Donya I'm gonna I'm gonna handle
this D3 break notes without saying hey
this is not so bad if you say Robert
either so I'm I don't care what I like
that I agree with you but I think the E4
Pawn is a target
um this control of the Center is nice
for white and black does need to play
Bishop D7 Knight C6 and then challenge
the white knight in D4 yeah I mean this
Knight is incredibly strong the bishop
on B2 lies in weight waiting for an
opportunity once the knights move away
and A3 very careful move by Fabio
restricting the mobility of black snipe
and it's just sort of a normal
complicated middle game I would
definitely choose white here at this
point though
yes and Rook D1 it's actually starting
to remind me of the game between uh
dingley ran with white against team over
Jabba from the candidates where things
started to look normal but then white
king is in the center and black just
strikes on the queen side with its A5
move and he gives up B4
that is a nasty little move there was
really no way around that if he had
taken on A5 he would have lost the pawn
on A3 and then he would have ended up
having to give up his Bishop on top of
losing one of the queen side Pawns do
not take on B7 Rook V8 will win the
bishop on B2 literally saying the same
thing yeah so Bobby's just playing his
equal material but he is down upon Arjun
is obsessed with pushing the H Pawn in
like every position
he's a player of this generation you
know just pushing the age one alpha
zeros there he goes again
but Fabian asks for it with G3 I don't
know if that was a necessary move
and he was Knight C2 so he's retreating
I thought he's gonna go Knight B5 SO
trading off pieces
okay you should think about taking B7
but still there was Rook ba trapping the
queen now the Knight
where is it going exactly
what's happening here just trade
everything
and I would shove that pawn down to H3
to create the preconditions for a back
rank made so important bullet Robert to
create these tactical precursors so that
you benefit in the event of a Time
scramble so that you just get more lucky
later on you can always adjust that
right now all these trades black has an
extra power
Knight G5 to F3 oh and the other night
can come in oh exactly yeah Knight G5
Knight F3 is curtains and if Knight E4
and Knight H2 King G1 knifely check is a
fork so oh great calculation down goes
everything
yep
and Rook A1 Knight G4 H2 I think Knight
G4 was a little bit sloppy but this
should still be a pretty easy win oh
good move King F3 though
this might be not yeah King comes back
to G2 defends everything
I mean all Arjun had to do was put his
own Rook on the first rank Robert and
then Fabi would have had no way to stop
the pawn now the scene has shifted right
bring that Knight
ah where's the Knight going Knight C4 B5
and then F3
I don't think you're in time but that's
what I'm looking at is it F3
wait what three and then still be five
but take five four but then I thought
Rook D2 there oh wait a second up the
pawn White's not even worse anymore
uh Arjun panicking here he's still
better though look at White's King
Knight H5 hunting hunting
and Rook d7's coming and where's that
black king going yeah who's hunting whom
King oh there's me threats Galore
okay take on G5 take on E5 so you can't
win a piece oh Knight F3 no the Knight
takes F3 and rookie two
and you were the wrong way he joined
King F2 I think is it anyway he's going
King Queen's side over here I can't even
say the words one second fabby's escaped
King C1 what was he a draw
where will we see a checkmate
it's a draw no Fabby going for it no
he's not
[Laughter]
what a game
we're still tied here in the SEC the
first matchup of this year's event it is
nine F9 F we get back to the English and
reverse Sicilian in fact and for five
minute karwana I mean he actually had
the lead on the clock down the stretch
that will be important for him but look
at Arjun God done it he says more time
than he started with yeah but those were
two big misses by Arjun the last game of
the three-minute portion and that last
game he was totally when he was one move
away from just ending the game outright
all credit to Fabby though he is
resilient as no I mean he is just
pulling off Magnus car level comebacks
here can he capitalize and win a game
here
he's got a great position look at
players have over a minute I think these
are the types of positions that Bobby
thrives in he is compact structure all
of his minor pieces are near each other
he's pushing pawns controlling the
brakes white is very passive and here
comes the Knight to G5 Pawn to F4 Pawn
to F3 I think that Arjun is in huge
trouble right now no he totally is he's
flopping about on the first couple of
ranks he's got this Pawn on B6 which is
normally a big asset in these positions
but there's just no year getting to the
B7 Pawn I love this decision by Arjun to
play D4 he has to change the nature of
the position push that pawn down to D5
open up the center and take the focus
off of the king side look at Bobby's
clock one unbelievable he's been
pre-moving he's been making good quick
choices and now he can look at that
Bishop d55 C8 taking the open file D5
will be loose the bishop longitude is in
tune back there
I like I know though I'm worried about a
potential sacrifice on F5 maybe you go
Queen before chip away at the king side
I think this is more double-edged than
it looks I'm with you that is a good
point if you actually attack on F5
that's trouble or sack on G4 even here
that could be a good practical option
again the key is to change the nature of
the Game Force black to defend for a
change Queen B4
so trade about Bishop H6 is a huge
moment for Fabi oh and then Queen C7
Bishop takes E3 the queen is defended
that's really important the queen is
defended there on D7 otherwise Queen C7
would almost win the game for White and
the bishop is totally imprisoned the
only way out is to push the E3 Pawn but
Robert that creates a massive weakness
on F3 this is looking really bad so
Argent needs to find a way Queen C7
Queen takes D5
oh yeah I didn't have a follow-up in
mind actually Mr takes D5 and I think so
did Argent
trusting you you know I'm like
I'm like but I'm trusting Dania over
here
okay so Knight C4 can just go after the
B6 Pawn it's weird how Black's pieces
are kind of stuck in no man's land
there's a lot of squares that Fabi has
to keep tabs on and he might have no
good way to make progress here as
strange as it sounds well Queenie Queen
F7 right
Queen d8 D5 and maybe it's time to play
E3 yes very good call
Bishop F1 and Bishop B5 oh my gosh you
could lose it and it's suddenly a three
result game but is that Knight coming to
F3 or is it going back to F7
I think it might need to go back to F7
and then still Bishop B8 comes in I
think Fabi is losing control of this
game oh Knight F3 check
oh and then there's Queen A1 yeah
King she's a really good move really
good move there by origin I mean Fabi
can still play Knight F3 but then
there's no mate threat
oh there's no check why doesn't even
have a single check and I'm worried oh
take some Bishop C6 takes him he missed
it that is sick
instead he takes D5 but now Queen A1
Queen G8 okay barely clinging onto that
Queen G8 Queen F7
oh Queen here goes the king queen C7
King fappy Bishop Bishop F7 he wins the
queen
oh no
oh honey falter is there and Arjun takes
the lead 10-9 but what we're seeing
though Dania is this is a match for both
players clearly have chances it's not
that one player better than the other
and bullet but that was a dagger an
absolute dagger but again Robert it all
comes down to the time scrambles that's
where Arjun has been getting him in all
of these time controls it's true when
the clock ticks low it's not Fabiano's
game anymore and here C5 Origins
striking on in the center and I honestly
thought that Arjun was white for a
second just based on yeah me too
yeah he's had this type of structure
with the white pieces now often white
tries to prepare E3 E4 now the bishops
get traded white has this monster Square
on D4 for the queen
so trade me says oh yep
so Rook F to B1
who will strike on the queen side first
would be white with B3 or black with B5
I think five is going for G4 there he
goes Rook G1
white is much better though right
because you play Rook G oh I don't know
I I think if blackened can squeeze
through B4 the landscape changes
completely
so he trades here it'll trade on F5 you
have to take with the E Pawn because H3
so he puts a quiet move there well he's
trying to make sure that the Rook on G1
can be delegated to the queen side in
the future I thought he's gonna play GF
kind of forcing EF and then play H4 H4
and he does press that great call so
that's why I was confused by H3 but
maybe there was a a pass essentially
so how is black in the defend this G6
phone it's Unthinkable to give up the G
file that is just immediate harakiri
maybe King E7 King F7 you can't play
Bishop E8 because there's the a file
tension as well
oh he goes all in he goes all in and
Fabi quickly takes it take an eight
good times you slow down if you're fappy
but you distract The Rook wait Bishop
takes Rook A1 hey can't take on B4 oh H5
also is good
I apologize no you're right though look
you by the movie you suggested Rook G6
and it's over f five four is it Rook G7
and E6
somehow it's actually hard to for white
to push the pawns isn't that weird it's
like the bishop is stuck in molasses it
looks just completely winning but Fabius
30 seconds calculator right now so he's
doing the right thing Rook G7 check
you may yeah Bishop H7 Paving the way
for the F Pawn
I like that a lot it's what Amman said
all of the cgc like he was when you have
a bishop move the Pawns in the opposite
color
yep five F6 yeah goodbye and you can
give up the bishop for the C Pawn I mean
look at Black's Bishop
what Bishop yeah exactly good one F7
goodbye
The Smithereens that game
these two cannot distance themselves
from each other they want tie breaks get
a room already I mean this is crazy
well everybody should stay right here
because this match is knotted up ten and
a half a piece neither side can break
free from the other and we see what
looks like a French defense from Fabi
over here a very quiet opening but he
does have the bishop here and once again
Arjun plays H4 yeah I mean no he's just
it's an addiction and Fabby says hey
give me a piece of that too he plays A5
yeah this is dubious for black very
passive construction there for Fabi
it's passive that's true but at some
point C5 will be available for black
and he plays it immediately I was
worried about D5 while the king is still
in the center
I also agree that D5 looks scary but
maybe D5 he'll just castle kingside and
say let's open this position up for my
Bishops oh he goes E5
establishing a stronghold on D6
obviously that he is defended by the
black dark Squad Bishop I also think
he's dreaming of putting a queen on e41p
but the bishop has something small to
say about that
mm-hmm
he goes again
the amount of Rook lifts we've seen it
makes sense but where is it going here
comes C4 for black
well at least there's no Knight on G3
this time
yeah that's true and then I would go to
H5 and that'd be a problem
you know what's a problem is the
possibility of Knight G5 although
White's just gonna black she's gonna
leave that Knight on G5 he's gonna say
big deal
F5
wow
that was a big Choice here it's a knight
F6 is there Knight G4 Queen E6 oh Eagle
tactical eye by you 20 seconds for Fabi
as he
puts that Bishop on D5 but in come the
Knight the knights are so good at
exploding those squares Knight takes H6
it's over oh my gosh Rook G3 to follow
with Knight G6 completely overlooked by
Fabi how quickly did that happen I mean
he had no pieces in the attack and now
every piece is in the attack
goodbye
completely overlooked by Fabi and a
great win for Arjun there
that honestly is such a confidence
booster that was a wire to wire Victory
yes and right after Bobby kind of had a
wire to wire Victory so these two are
trading off games right now and what is
this
French
a lot of pawn moves none of which I
fully understand but the players
certainly do because they're blitzing
out all their moves as usual isn't the
E4 Pawn just an issue to deal with can
we just all calm down for a second here
and just let me Castle's Queen side what
queen
what is happening this is completely
Beyond me and I think there's just bad
play by Arjun
and he grabs the pawn but look at his
King look at his King
I'm so confused by everything that's
happened in this game A4 I don't know
about that move either he took it
isn't Rook C1 and Bishop C6 about to
happen
what is happening in this game I'm just
as I think everybody's clueless right
now he doesn't take the pawn immediately
he's gonna go Bishop C6 he's just gonna
Checkmate that black king he says get
out of B7
that's like when my mom needed me to get
out of school she'd throw the blanket
off get up
it's party time
Queen F4 okay we are gonna see a queen
trade it looks like
are we oh Queen C2 Rook D2 oh oh no but
then maybe Queen B3
on Queen B4
what a ridiculous version how is Arjun
doing this how is he not checkmated
he is somehow found tactics that work
out because if rookie took Quincy
through his Queen D4 check right so you
can oh Queen F2 is also probably leading
to an attack so yes worse comes to worst
there's Queen F4 to B for
which all of which I think Fabi missed
yes it's just an extra Pawn for Arjun
I feel like you have to keep the Queens
on the board you're going to lose if you
trade Queens here with 24 seconds but
isn't there Bishop C5 check now
and then what Rook F2 you know what I do
is I take on B7 there give up my queen
yup you're absolutely right that is the
Practical call there he goes
and that's the sign of an improving
bullet player somebody who just goes
with it understanding okay sexy blunder
the bond is it a mate
oh Arjun is just he's been so sloppy
this game
is done
unreal I mean he has to play Queen D4
not totally over yet though can you
can't take on A7 it's not winning I
don't like Rook takes A7 at all it's a
bad bullet decision
two pieces for a rook is always hard to
handle in a bullet game he could have
moved his H Pawn First
yeah there was no rush the bishop wasn't
going anywhere still better for white
but I think arjun's gonna pull out a
draw here I think he's gonna pull out a
draw very good chances Rook B5 B5 yep
but look at Bobby he's going after these
kingside pawns H5 perhaps but is he
sending them where they want to go
anyway yeah if he goes
h54 G3 but it only finds G5 and King
interesting try
it's a three result game now it's a
three result game but no but F3 Knight
takes G4 is huge oh and and Rook G2 King
H3 yeah you have the outside whoa whoa
oh it's winning though there goes the
h-pawn on us too fast it's too fast
Black's gonna stop the pawn with his
Rook but here comes but the king is cut
off look at that
King G5 and then H7 Rook G8 no h76 H7
here
president it's a G2 Pawn is so important
Arjun trying everything he can and Fabi
let him go
he let him get his Pawn to E4 and how is
he gonna draw this though move move oh
he's 1.4 seconds Queen me oh no he's a
loud promotion
rugby in no time it was still a draw
after Rook B8
because he goes Rook B8 Rook B7 right
after Bishop G8
and and the thing is Robert if if Fabi
promoted there black takes to get his
King to G3 and then he uses the E Pawn
to distract the white Bishop unmooring
it from the pawn it's a classic
mechanism but he had about a millisecond
to figure it out
and this again is just an epic 11 and a
half eleven and a half 12 plus minutes
remaining in the bullet here look at
this Fabi saying I'll play the French
myself you've been doing love with it
Arjun let's go okay just like King B1
are you serious oh and the point the
point the point is that after HD Knight
G5 there's no Fork on F4
there's no Fork on that fork
great response though by Bobby going
night before let's get that Bishop off
the board but King B1 that is a stellar
tactical move by our speed belts speed
belts ladies and gentlemen make sure
they're tightly fastened across your lap
we've got 12 minutes on the nose oh
Bishop A6 watch out for that
yep that's coming
no Bishop A6
or queen of five check would have been
sufficient forget I said anything okay I
will try my best everything defend in
Black's position just looks good for
black
yeah two Bishops solid game
Knight coming F6 now potentially maybe
B5 B4 that's a pretty committal sequence
but he plays it
Knight B6 as well
yep now Fabi is totally in control here
thus far in this game yeah he's playing
a great game Knight C1 origin kind of
floundering around the E6 Pawn is a
weakness you gotta keep tabs on it whoa
oh because 94 trade in 94 and The Rook
gets trapped in E6 as well what
positional Acumen with no time I mean
how do you find this in a bullet game
just that sense of where the pieces
belong is amazing he's just better at
bullet than anybody giving credit for oh
totally even himself I think he would be
harsher about his own bullet than
anybody I thought he could have taken on
D2 and traveled to C2 with his Queen but
instead he tries to keep the Knight on
the board
maneuver it to D3 Rook C2 there's Knight
D4 okay can't get away with that he
wants to provoke more weaknesses on the
queen side uh why not
this looks so scary for the white king
maybe Rook B3 should be tried shaking
the black pieces off of their incredible
posts
me too
it's holding on
Bishops before patient move by Fabby
yeah here comes Queen A5 and rookie okay
it's devastating on Queen E5 also
hanging and rookie it's gonna follow
next oh he plays five six any second now
literally look how much time he has no
it's crazy it's over pawn and A2 cannot
be defended Queen A3
it is impossible to defend this with
five seconds even if there were a
defense you're not saving this game if
you're urgent although we've seen Arjun
pull out some crazy comebacks he's
somehow still kicking Robert how is he
doing this I don't know
Knight C1
still in the game
unbelievable defense by origin right now
regardless of how 93. oh here comes the
knights Pawn D4
back to B4 look at how the bishop has
yacht back and forth it goes covering
all the squares night I was gonna Knight
F4 he wants Knight D4
wow delicious
he's doing better than he was like five
moves Ago by a lot but Here Comes The
Rook to E2 it goes
oh this is amazing
Bishop A6 oh A4
it's it's true I'm Queen e3 coming in
Rook takes G2 just take some pawns Fabby
he does and queen e Queen C6 oh queen of
course the queen trade oh my God no
Bishop F3 Bishop F3 blinders
he wasn't even losing and then he
blundered at the last possible hurdle
Bishop E2 wait up nope he got it
um yeah should be a win and he resigns
and Fabby is up by one
what a turn of events there this is
absolutely crazy and I just want to
remind everybody because they keep
taking a one-game lead and going back to
even if this ends in a tie we have four
games of one plus one bullet and if
that's still tied we get to Armageddon
with bidding so this is crazy stuff Fabi
up 12 and a half 11 half and now we're
getting a benoni of all openings and so
important for Arjun not to panic I mean
he can hypothetically even afford to
lose another game he shouldn't blow this
up in his mind to be a must-win game he
just needs to play solid and to play the
position and he's not doing that
his position is terrible I think Fabby
could strike with E5 here just smash
through in the center at some point
he's just putting his Bishop on F5
saying can't touch this and this is so
ugly Knight D1 E3 and then over to C4 G4
this is just positionally lost Can't
Touch This and like Knight is just gonna
Hammer at home when it gets to C4 oh but
he blunders Knight takes D5
I'm so proud of my reference he does
still bad for black though that tells
you a lot about how bad the position was
it was a good reference though by the
way just let you know thank you okay as
long as you acknowledge that I'm good no
but yeah that was not something Fabby
should have blundered no not at all now
black is right back in this game and
watch out for like Knight H5 at some
moment the F6 square is vulnerable
Knight F5 as well so all of these light
squares are white for the taking so
Queen F6 is met by Knight H5 oh huh and
he walks into it I think it was
deliberate
I think he had Queen to F5 there
challenging White's Queen getting out of
the fork now Knight takes D6 is a huge
threat well maybe not a huge threat
but a threat nonetheless
same page
because G4 tiasco G3
be very careful about some Queen takes
three four Knight F6 tricks if the
Knight moves out of E5 not anymore
yeah and if Rook takes you Knight takes
you three all of these squares are still
whites for the taking so we see a trade
with the H5 is bad news for white God
fabby's position has gotten so much
worse he blundered that pawn and now
he's allowed the Knight to establish
itself on E5 Arjun could follow up with
F5 if he wants to control more squares
The Rook comes to h8 so but King F1 will
always be available the Knight is really
well placed in G3 and Fabi has to try to
squeeze his Knight in through F5 maybe
even in exchange stock on E5 at some
point can be considered
he plays quit 93
oh they both missile that was just a
fork yeah
well 93 Knight F5 check maybe they saw
but then just King F6 even is winning
now Bobby still some Chances with the
King on f8 being iffy the King on G1 is
actually surprisingly safe thanks to the
Knight on G3 yeah watch out for Brook
takes E5 as you mentioned in the worst
case scenario the Knight can block the
check on F1 Rook takes C5 wait and queen
F6 oh Queen d8 oh
oh my gosh Queen H6 Queen d8 oh and
there's a fork on F5 if you go Queen H6
and if you go Queen G6 you drop the Rook
on h8 oh my God oh my God
Arjun needs to think about resigning I
mean I know it's hard to do that because
you're even up upon here Queen d8 95
maybe you still like found a way to
reshuffle he's going to lose in exchange
but that 995 means the game isn't over
wow it's far from over not even worse
apparently whoa he didn't take the
Knight Queen G8 checkpoint F3
Queen
Queen h8 yeah that was winning oh but
that was an incredible tactic Knight F3
and now black is winning I think or is
he oh my gosh this queen get out of here
get out of here Queen F7 king queen F1
no
[Laughter]
is it there's so many checks right no
but it's got to be winning
um
I'm so confused by this game King F3 is
King F now black has to be very careful
not to get mated not to blunder a queen
but he just takes on F2 and the match is
going to be tight again
when you see Maiden one look for Maiden
two that's what we just learned but it
is a tied match yeah I thought that it
was resignable and then all of a sudden
it was Arjun wins that's the nature
bullet for you that's the nature of this
match ladies and gentlemen it is tied
with four minutes left the tension
continues to escalate how nervous must
the players be what must their hearts be
beating at right now I'm nervous I mean
this has been just such an up and down
match it has been absurd and right out
Finance position is extremely solid he
has more time than he started with he
should be feeling pretty decent about
this game Risk Management is very
important here I think Fabio should try
to play solid and he is and he's gotten
exactly what he wants to get in a bullet
game Bishop pair no weaknesses
this does look very trash I think it
would end in a drawing a Blitz game but
I think draw is out of their vocabulary
in the bullet segment
we've had only one draw if I'm not
mistaken in the bullet so they keep
trading on victories F5 good move from
Fabiano there could be G5 in the near
future
but H4
Queen G7
there could be an exchange sack on E7
though that's exactly right H4 Queen G7
actually white needs to be very careful
to avoid just like flat out losing a
piece here
right so I'm already looking at the
exchange sack on E7 though H4 27 Rook
takes E7 and so on
okay Knight B3 what a calm move by Arjun
Paving the way for the bishop to drop
back but
not a move you play with a
you know with a smile on your face
no and Fabi because he was moving so
quickly he has the time to use right now
spending almost 20 seconds as did Arjun
on that move rookie eight just defending
the bishop offering some trade soon with
Bishop six
okay Bishop drops back to D7 covering
the E6 Square H4 is still on the horizon
instead he drives it back
I'm starting to like this for black you
just have a bishop pair with no
compensation for white just a slightly
better position no risk trade Queens but
we know how strong Knights are in bullet
games that sounds like a very primitive
point but where there is a knight in the
center there are forks and there are
tactics in fact you're doing a great job
of restricting the knight's Mobility
covering the B5 Square
and just protecting the F5 Pawn
wait a second Knight F3 Maybe
what you don't want is this dark spot
Bishop tree that's why Fabi goes back to
f8 oh oh oh
[Music]
now the good news for Fabi is that the
check on h8 is innocuous for the time
being
it's just one check I play King F7 at
some point
he goes back
I thought Queen D5 was a good practical
chance but this time looked good Bishop
C6 has great scope F4 uh-oh the Knight
getting pushed around crazy for the F3
that's huge for white
striking at every side of the board Fabi
going for the queen trade love that
decision risk manage very smart very
very smart move risk management but this
obviously gives Argent decent chances to
draw in fact I think he should hold if
he doesn't blunder
if he does nothing essentially just go
bishop move back and forth another good
move by Fabi fixing his body
blundered I just said don't do anything
for goddess Bishop was defended now he's
losing his pawns oh my gosh with one
minute to play if he loses this game he
will have to win on demand the next game
is going to be the last and that's why
he's resigned because they're still 50
seconds this will be the final game and
if Fabiano looked at the match clock he
might play something a little bit
simplistic no tactics he is doing just
that that's exactly what he's doing all
fappy needs is a draw a draw wins the
match for fappy this is gonna be the
last game of the match here we go here
we go before he's pushing his possible
that's the thing right you can't just do
nothing you do have to play some normal
decisions but already I feel like for
origin his all his peace on the king
side he'll move his Knight and play F5
he'll just oh Robert E4 that gave up so
many squares on the queen side I didn't
think he should have rushed to that move
I get what he's doing though
I think he's in trouble look at the a
file opening up and The Rook linen A7
the C6 square is White's for the taking
and I just don't see it in attack oh and
Rook A7 driving the rook in and Knight C
oh it takes distracted away no in fact
look at fabby's clock look at fabby's
clock he's feeling it he understood he's
absolutely feeling it he understands you
know the match strategy at this point
right he's just playing quiet good chess
and Arjun has to take the risk and now
arjun's down a pawn he has no attack
whatsoever Knight C6 at any moment
forces more pieces off no this is
and this is not one of those lost
positions I mean black is zero piece
activity his only chance I think maybe
go G5 G4 you're praying for a blunder at
this point for fat from Fabi
yeah it doesn't look like it gets you
anywhere uh realistically speaking and
so just I like that move though open up
the center oh was that Mouse slip
probably
because
Queen defy those Rook takes C7 so maybe
it actually wasn't a mouse that dude
Fabi is playing with the quality of a
classical game he's literally playing
the best moves yeah it is a great
showing from him uh the only good news
for origin right now is the position is
locked up which means that well H4 is
also just dropping so there is no good
news three pawns down is our generic icy
he still can't play G5 because there was
a fork on F5 and look at how the Rooks
are defending each other nicely
those knights in the dark squares for
Arjun the C7 pawns hanging and maybe oh
it wasn't hanging The Rook on A1 was
loose oh
okay check on B2 another devastating
weakness provoked if the Knight lands on
E6 you can resign immediately
okay but D5 is now threatened
God kudos to Arjun for keeping pieces on
the board somehow yeah that's the pond
it's two extra pawns for white but
somehow it doesn't quite feel like that
Rook takes C7 Rook takes seven that's
the match game anytime there it is
Fabiano caruana finds it he knows it's
over and he is gonna move on to the
round of eight the quarterfinals will
aware it is oh my gosh Argent era geisi
I mean he put up a great fight in this
match but Fabiano caruana with his back
against the wall he takes it home and
bullet Donya that was amazing I mean I
am so impressed at his composure his
speed his quality of play that was an
absolutely epic Opening match Arjun he's
got to keep his head up high but he
allowed that three that four point
streak early in the match that set the
tone it was all Fabby in the bullet what
a match
seriously that was epic stuff first it
was Arjun in the five plus one then it
was Fabian three plus one and then it
was a toss-up but when all is said and
done Fabiano caruana he wins this match
by two points he moves on to face the
winner of Magnus Carlson and gukash so
in all likely that will be Carlson and
we'll see a rematch of the 2018 World
Chess Championship which is decided in
Rapid so Donna that is exciting stuff
for the Fabiano caruana fans around the
world listen we got we just got
courtside seats to yet another amazing
SEC match there's just magic in the air
anytime it's SCC season and Fabiano
caruana again and again proving that he
needs to be considered among the best
bullet players in the world stop with
the narrative that Fabiano isn't going
to Bullet he isn't good at Blitz because
he's disproven it again and again over
the last couple of years and this is
just another case in point
look up his feed a blitz rating at
something like 28.50 he's been an
absolute monster and he is not slowing
down at least not for Arjun aragaisy but
we got to keep our hats off to Arjun who
played a great match who won the junior
speed Chess Championship and if he
didn't get flustered there uh when he
was up by three point he started losing
the thread and you saw it slipping from
him he was emotional in the way we've
never seen before uh but he put up a
really good fight it was an epic match
everybody went straight to it and well
speaking of treats we're going to bring
Fabiano caruana in for an interview so
we're gonna get that set up so stay
tuned to hear the thoughts the winner of
this match Fabiana carwana in just a few
minutes
[Music]
thank you
you know historically in Third Ward you
would have more formal places for folks
to get together corner stores cafes but
you know through the history of the
neighborhood you've had a lot of
disinvestment over the years I mean
starting from the 1930s you had
redlining and so the area where the
chess parking was a formerly redlined
part of Houston and when they came and
built highways in the 1950s they you
know tore through sections of Third Ward
separating it from the rest of the city
and that just left huge swaths of the
neighborhood empty and vacant
park into an area where people can come
enjoy themselves feel safe
um
just kind of doing things piece by piece
incrementally so kind of a tactical
urbanism approach we're not waiting on
the city to do any Grand project we're
just doing what we can do step by step
as private citizens and working together
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
carwana the winner of that Opening match
against Argent aragaisi and my most
important first question for you Fabi is
are you watching the World Cup
no not at all I Christian asked me this
too I don't really follow football or
soccer every month I just don't I don't
enjoy it and so I like follow the
results a bit but I don't really like
watching it
Fabby the match was amazing it was such
a treat to watch let's go back to the
end of the five minute portion when you
mount to that Furious four-point
comeback how did you coach yourself uh
in the moment that you were down three
points because you just seemed like a
new man toward the end of the five
minute portion in the start of the three
minute portion what exactly did you tell
yourself how did you change your
mentality
I I was just glad to be done with the
five minute I felt like I was getting
outplayed and even when I wasn't gaining
at getting out of plate I was getting
flagged or flagging myself more more
specifically uh so I I thought that like
in five minutes was was like so slow and
I'm playing worse than him uh I think he
was also playing very well so it's not
like you know it was all because I was
playing poorly but uh he was putting
pressure on me and and then I remembered
that in a lot of matches from the other
side I was up in the five minute like
against Duda and then
uh it usually came down to Bullet uh
which would be very close to tide so I
figured that if I kept it relatively
level that the bullet would probably
decide it uh and I just wanted not to
get tilted like I was getting a bit
tilted in the five minute at some point
because I was really I spoiled some good
positions I I got flagged in like a dead
drone position which was I had like six
seconds and then I just let it run my
time run out uh so everything was going
wrong and I just was very happy that it
got a bit faster I could play more
intuitively I didn't have to
um
didn't have to like stress over my
decisions
and it's interesting because you were
just talking about how time trouble was
kind of your biggest enemy in the
longest time Patrol portion so how does
that work like how do you sort of
convince yourself that your struggles in
the first segment they can be uh you
know pushed aside in quicker time
controls which seemed at least the time
scrambles to be your problem early on
yeah it completely shifted I didn't
expect it to shift so much that the time
scrambles worked more in my favor in the
three and one minute portions while in
the in the five minute it was the other
way around
um I don't know I think it was because I
also tried to keep a lead on the clock
in the three in one minute which I
usually managed very slightly but anyway
that that time buffer does does play a
role while in the five minute I was
routinely down one or two minutes which
is uh
yeah it's it's you're really putting
yourself on the back foot uh and I also
had this disastrous second game I mean I
just I played a line which I knew is
good for black but couldn't remember and
then I just lost on the spot
um I think the move after C3 is 92 but I
I just um
also it's very stupid because if you
don't remember but it's a five minute
game so you have time you might as well
calculate which is not not what I did at
all I just blundered 94 maybe White's
winning another way so
um
so yeah the five minute didn't go my way
in any any station I also felt like I
was just a weaker player like in the
first few games I just felt like Arjun
is just outplaying me and
um before the match I thought it might
be 50 50 but then I started to
reconsider once he started out playing
me in every game
uh but
yeah luckily things turned around
fatty one last question for me how
carefully are you going to be following
the matchup of your potential opponent
in the next round Magnus Carlson against
kukashian do you think gukash has any
realistic chances at all to pull off an
upset
uh I will follow all the matches pretty
closely especially that one because it
decides who I play but I think I already
said this
um
on my podcast that
I feel like Magnus is close like 95 plus
favorite
um not not to take anything away from
gukesh who's very good but I don't know
if Magnus has lost very very few matches
against anyone and I I've never seen
googesh play online
like I don't know if I think he doesn't
really enjoy it that's what I heard that
he prefers to focus on
um classical chess which maybe he
considers more serious chess
so without that experience of Magnus
being so dominant in these uh formats
traditionally it would have to be an off
day for Magnus or googes would just have
to to have the best day of his life I
feel for it to to be a uh a win for
Lucas
yeah totally fair and last question from
me uh speaking of the c-squared podcast
you gave really some High Praise to
Arjun Eric ice age can you elaborate on
that you said that he you felt was the
most likely to reach 2800 Did you sort
of feel that strength in this match and
you know what do you see to come from
him and these juniors
uh well it's difficult I I had to pick
someone it was difficult of course
because all these Indian juniors are so
strong and we saw for example nihal
recently going to the final of the uh
Global championship and
um and prognanta is always so strong and
good cash and is 27.40 now uh but I
thought that Arjun like the quality of
his play is sometimes Incredible without
with very few mistakes and also in In
classical chess I remember being uh
extremely impressed when he won the Tata
steel B group
completely dominantly and with you know
so such Precision in his chest that that
you see from very few players uh so I
feel like he's a very classy player he
has a lot of potential because of course
he's young and he has his uh his minuses
as well lack of experience and uh all
the associated things that come with
being in you know up and coming player
he he doesn't have some of the tools
that more experienced guys have but I
could I could see him being 2800 one day
I wouldn't be surprised at all I would
even put it at a higher than 50 chance
but it could also be that you know
there's multiple uh Indian Juniors who
reach that level
I wouldn't be surprised as well because
let's say for my generation
almost all players at some point hit
um or players that I consider you know
near my generation like Anish Wesley
ding
um
Eon uh Hikaru I mean of course Magnus
Island
um we don't even speak about it but uh
you know all these players who have a
lot of potential they tend to at some
point reach the
the top of their potential so I I
wouldn't be surprised at all for Arjun
as well
we have a feature chat question Bobby
before we let you go are you excited to
face Arjun again in tata Steel in just a
couple of weeks I think
yeah it's I haven't thought too much
about the tournament yet because it
still feels like there's a lot to do
um but it is my next event after this
one oh well actually I shouldn't say
that I'll probably play the world Rapids
Championship uh but yeah it feels like
there's a lot to come before that so I
haven't thought about it too much it
would be the first time that I've played
him in classical which is interesting
because we played some Rapids and Blitz
actually I I should say not rapid only
Blitz but uh but the classical you've
never played so it will be interesting
well we're super excited for that but
we're also excited first for you to play
in the next round here at the speed test
Championship Bobby you know it's been a
long and tough match but congrats again
for coming on top and we'll see you in
the next round
thanks guys thank you
see you Bobby that was Grand Master
Fabiano caruana the U.S chess champion
commentator extraordinaire uh Dustin off
the good old Blitz and bullet skills and
taking down Arjun aragaisi so Dania I
mean really impressive stuff from him he
will await the winner of Magnus and
gooka she called Magnus a 95 favorite
but I think everybody wants to see that
rematch of the 2018 World Championship
oh most certainly and I'm excited for
the Magnus match I mean bukash is uh a
wild card in like the other sense of the
word you just don't know how he's going
to do he's not very experienced in
online chess so this is not a walkover
for the world champion but obviously
let's be real Magnus is the heavy
favorite and akarowana Carlson rematch
in round two would be straight up fire
as of course are the other matches from
the first round of the SCC so let's not
jump the gun here we've got plenty of
entertainment to go around on all sides
of the screen I feel like I haven't said
Wesley so's name a single time in this
broadcast so I'm just gonna give a shout
out to our finalists from a year ago
Wesley so he always seems to do well in
this format he's only lost to a car or
Magnus he just won the cgc so before I
forget he takes on noribek abdusatov in
their first round matchup but we have
great upcoming matchups for you not just
the one I mentioned but you see dingley
Ren against Alexander Grisha this Sunday
November 27th you can see on on the 28th
nepo and mvl on the 30th Lavon aronian
Dimitri on draken and Magnus Carlson he
comes back to speeches championship and
takes on gukesh in their first round
matchup on Tuesday December 6. so Dania
I mean seriously we had so much fun
today what are your kind of final
thoughts about what we saw and the
display from both Fabiano and Arjun well
first of all I'm just so grateful to
have a chance to cover these matches
it's been so fun I have a classical game
in three and a half hours I could not
have asked for a better way to get
warmed up than to watch two absolute
monsters at play but at the end of the
day it's all about disproving that
narrative I think chess players and
chess fans are often prone to recency
bias and they're prone to vast
generalizations and preconceived notions
and they're just these reputations that
players develop and a lot of them are
totally unfounded and Fabi just
continues to show that again and again
and again Arjun is such an exciting
young player to watch Fabi has the
highest praise for him we saw him
elaborating in the interview but at the
end of the day Fabiana carwana is back
he is gaining momentum he won the US
championship and he just seems fresh he
seems motivated and excited to play and
that's when Fabiano is at his absolute
best
never shocked when Fabi is fresh but he
has won an opening round matchup two
years in a row first beating Maxine
Russia lagrav in 2021 now defeating
Arjun aragaisy here in this year's
opening matchup so it was a great
showing by Arjun uh Fabiano gave him the
utmost respect and praise saying this is
a player he believes will reach 2800 but
today was not his day today was fabianos
and he moves on to face the winner of
Magnus Carlson and gukesh but on behalf
of chess.com Dania it's been an absolute
blast covering with you like to see
everybody soon for more from the speed
Chess Championship brought to you by
chess.com but enjoy your holidays first
and then we'll resume action with dingly
Wren versus Alexander grishuk
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
felicans